foreign
good morning everybody Welcome to
environment agriculture
we have a
full plate of hearings this morning and
this afternoon so uh without
any further
uh tearing we should get started here
I will open the hearing for a house bill
and here this morning to introduce this
bill
is representative Peter Bixby
good morning
so uh House Bill 221 is a department
request and uh what it does is it makes
a modif minor modification in the soil
conservation and farmland preservation
subdivision of RSA 432 and this section
deals with uh acquisition of
agricultural land development rights as
a way to preserve farmland
currently the state biased that they
want to preserve and it has to be this
and the development rights have to be
deeded to the state and this Arrangement
actually impedes the possibility of how
much Farmland we can preserve because
it's not possible to get a third party
to purchase the farmland and just make
sure that the deed is uh is carried out
so what this bill does is it it adds a
line adds half a sentence to the statute
saying that uh the state has uh can
either buy the land or have the right to
enforce the deed restrictions and uh so
I'm going to say if you have questions
um please direct them to the
commissioner
thank you representative Bixby does
anybody have oh you're deferring your
questions to to the commissioner
thank you
everybody
okay fine yes sir
uh thank you madam chair I was just
wondering as a new member of the
committee relatively inexperienced could
you give us an example of this kind of
third party
uh purchase uh that's in the statement
representative uh he
he has deferred his questions to the
commissioner so when the commissioner
comes up to testify you are more than
welcome to ask him
thank you
so at this time I'll call commissioner
Sean Jasper to testify on House Bill 221
thank you
and good morning
good morning Madam chairman members of
the committee for the record I am Sean
Jasper commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture markets and
food and I am here in support of House
Bill 221 and I want to thank
representative Bixby for putting this
bill in at rbhest
essentially the department
um has not been in the business of
purchasing development rights since
l-chip came along but we do hold about
86 D or deed restrictions on properties
around the state
it is difficult for us to properly
by ourselves and we do have some help on
that but what the current statute does
is limit our ability really to protect
as much land as we could
currently most of the land that is
protected around the state now whether
it be agricultural forestry is done
through multiple parties including the
land trusts there are land trusts that
serve every cover every part of the
state they tend to be much better
stewards of watching out what's going on
there's also money available through
the USDA and
some of those restrictions make it
possible impossible for us to act in
concert with others this would modernize
the statute and allow us to be a player
in this and not have to
um
simply hold hold the title or the deed
restrictions ourselves and I think this
is a much better model that might still
happen we might still be the only ones
on some smaller Parcels but when we get
into the the larger Parcels which are
really the ones we
um should be protecting
um we're never going to be able to to do
that with the amount of money that we
have so this is our solution to make
um the department a once again player
and part participating in this and
working with others to make that happen
and I'll be glad to answer any questions
um I did hear that the question that was
asked so one that's ongoing right now is
in the town of Greenland a great Bay
Farm
and it is um involves salt which is the
southeast land trust it involves l-chip
and it involves the town of Greenland
itself so those three parties have come
together to to purchase the development
rights on that piece of property which
is part of Great Bay Farm and
um and so obviously if we had this
statue in place we would have been able
to be a player in that uh that as well
thank you Mr commissioner representative
knabb
hi madam chair thank you very much I was
wondering if the commissioner could
speak to is this considered a secondary
easement holder is that the role that
the department would take on you may ask
your question directly to the
commissioner oh thank you yes uh that's
exactly what we would be for instance in
uh in the case of what's going on in
Greenland I'm not sure who who the
underlying a holder is it could be
Greenland it could be salt
um and that would be the type of things
that we would continue to do l-chip is
not a primary holder
on any any of the
uh really want to be and so we would
then
give up no rights because we would be
able to uh enforce the terms and that's
the important thing it's not that we
hold it ourselves it's our ability to go
in if we see something going on and find
we could go in and enforce those rights
as a secondary holder
any other questions from the committee
representative smart
thank you madam chair I was just
wondering if there and and you might
have spoken to this and it went over my
head
um if there's anything in place to
um for to protect the property from the
state where if say in the future they
think it's better to run a highway
through it or put a municipal parking or
low-income housing or what do they call
it now affordable housing I
my recollection of any of these deeds
and I'm sorry that's if I'm getting too
far away from the mic but I usually
project pretty well yeah
um there is always the risk of eminent
domain in these if the state has a
higher use any of the Deeds I've ever
seen
but really that has just been for
Highway
um in new New Hampshire I don't think
we really go much beyond that not for
private development I think as I recall
there was a constitutional amendment
that was passed a few years ago because
of that concern of the state acting on
behalf of private entities
so I know for instance as I'm a
non-voting member of l-chip there's a
road up north that needed to be
relocated on land that we had an
interest in and so yeah that road is
going to be relocated uh it will take a
small small amount
but that is about the only thing that
I'm that I'm aware of and the good thing
about
having multiple people hold interest in
this in my opinion one thing that people
don't realize is that when an easement
is held that is a a bundle of Rights but
the the land itself is still held by
someone else
and so for instance if and I'll use the
town of Hudson if the town of Hudson
held an interest in a parcel
and then there was a landowner if the
land holder
made a offer of enough money to the town
the town could sell that bundle of
rights back to the landowner and then
that deed can go away
because it's held in by one one person
and people don't think that is possible
but but there is no magical thing where
development rights go away and can never
be reclaimed but they can they can be if
all the bundle of Rights end up in the
same place so having multiple interest
holders here is much more likely to
prevent that from happening because the
state potentially could sell its
interest but
for instance salt or some other landown
would still have their interest l-chip
would still have their interest and it
would be almost uh impossible to for
that underlying landowner to bring all
of those rights back together again
thank you and I uh representative roulog
thank you madam chair uh commissioner
who puts the restrictions on on the
Deeds does the department do that the
deed restrictions generally the ones we
have yes
so it what I'm suggesting here is that
whoever
the underlying holder would be would put
those restrictions on
potentially it could be us still in in
some cases but we would have that right
to enforcement so that if for instance a
land trust or a town decided to look the
other way
and say oh we really don't care we're
okay with what they're doing if it
violated the terms of
the easement the state of New Hampshire
could still step in and enforce those
rights Mitch so if I follow up yeah so
if I'm a farmer and I say oh you know I
I want to have cattle and the department
would say well you can't have cattle but
he can have produce
generally I mean that would be something
that I don't think we would ever want to
see in a deed all of the Deeds that I'm
aware of really cover agricultural
production and
there are certain things that we've
learned over the years
um that we want to be more clear on
agritourism is is a big part of that now
and so in some cases and there's there's
a case that uh it's not a case but an
instance in Westmoreland where it was
very clear you couldn't land airplanes
there they were doing that you couldn't
use it for parking they were doing that
and we said the terms of the deed do not
allow that had you wanted to do that you
could have said there would be X number
of events allowed per year on this
agricultural land so those things need
to be spelled out in advance and in this
case they were pretty specific that they
couldn't happen
um and so while it had been going on
was eventually discovered that there was
that violation we said no you can't do
this anymore thank you
uh representative Howard
thank you madam chairman
um did did this um commission hold the
right to enforce this in the past or the
state hold the right to enforce this in
the past and we lost it and now we're
getting it back no no we hold it now the
problem is we haven't been able to be we
haven't been able to play with others if
you will it's either us holding the
right all by ourselves which limits the
size of the land the amount of money
that we have because we don't have a law
we've been putting about 250 000 a year
into the fund over the last few years
so it doesn't give us a lot if you're
talking huge acreage but um so this
would just simply allow us to
participate with others because very
often there's not enough money out there
to take advantage of and some of it's
matching for instance the money with the
USDA there's a match
excuse me so
even l-chip and the land trusts would be
able to access some money but with us
coming in we'd be able to access more so
that the the total really increases
and this is really about getting more
money into uh from from the feds and you
know is why I want us to be a player is
to access that money we keep leaving
money on the table in the in the federal
Farm Bill
thank you
um I have a question in so far as
enforcement
it says the state shall have the right
to enforce the terms of the deed what
what types of things are included in
enforcement is there legal action is
there what there is legal action if
necessary
um
I am not aware of us having to take
legal action but that is a possibility
we go out now we find violations we work
with the landowner to correct those
those deficiencies
this makes sure that we still have the
ability to go on to the land I'm going
to assume we would do that in concert
with the other
um
players
but it gives us another set of eyes and
the ability to go in and as I said if
somebody said ah we don't really care
about this but we cared about it we
would still have that right to go to
court if if we felt it necessary it
doesn't it doesn't
say that we all have to agree if we see
a deed violation we have the independent
right to enforce the violation
okay thank you uh
representative Potenza
so just a question about the example
that you gave in regards with Great Bay
Farm so if this um this act takes effect
60 days just because some of these
things take a very long time to see
fruition is there any opportunity for
the state to get involved in this one
that you said that you gave it as an
example
um no that money is all closed all done
okay they're just down to survey work
right now gotcha
is there anything else that's what this
could affect that's in the works no I
think
if we get get there I've still got to
update the rules and and get there so
um I don't think so but under the state
law right now we do have money available
so potentially we could still be acting
by ourselves and we could do that
afterwards this isn't this is a either
or situation
okay
thank you um
do I see any other questions
representative NAB
curiosity but
some land in our town that's held by the
Department of Agriculture and easement
and I don't know that I've ever seen a
monitoring report so I'm just do you
have a or do you usually Outsource it
anyhow
um inspectors from the Department of
regulatory services our requirement is
to inspect it every two years reports
are made
I only see them if there's a problem
quite frankly
um and I know we
I think we do work with some other
agencies I got obvious honestly don't
think we we don't pay anybody anything
to do it but I need to look into that a
little bit a little bit more but the
monitoring is done to the best of our
ability and I'm not going to tell you
I'm satisfied with everything there's
one piece of property that I recently
spoken to the developer the director
about that we need to step out in
enforcement on that it's just
becoming very trashy
not productive
thank you uh I don't see any other pink
cards are there any other folks who are
interested in uh testifying on this bill
okay thank you thank you Mr commissioner
we appreciate your input and uh
I would like to remind members of the
committee that if you have a follow-up
question you need to ask for a follow-up
question and we don't want to get into a
situation of back and forth conversation
so
it's missing information
with that I'm going to close this commit
this hearing on hb221
all right
okay thank you
so we will uh begin a hearing I will
open the hearing on HB 138 relative to
the oversight of the commissioner of the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food
and here to introduce hb138
is representative Bixby thank you so um
uh HP 138 is another department request
and
I've just handed out a double-sided
piece of testimony
um and that that is uh simply because uh
there are the text of the bill simply
says repeal this line repeal this line
and repeal this line and I thought it
would be a little it would be convenient
for people to know what those what was
in those lines
so uh
there are basically two things that are
being repealed by this bill one is the
um
uh one is the oversight of the
commissioner of uh the Department of
Agriculture for uh clerical staff for
the State Board of veterinary medicine
uh a couple years back the State Board
of veterinary medicine got moved from
the Department of Agriculture to the
office of
um professional licensure and
uh and so all of its functions are now
over there there are no staff in the
department uh for the board of
veterinary medicine and there never will
be again so uh this line is sort of an
orphan uh and just should go away
um the uh second thing that's being
repealed is uh in the past there uh New
Hampshire had quarantine facilities for
equines uh to make sure that they didn't
have a disease called equine
contagious equine meritritis or cem
and metritis not meritris metroiditis
and
the state no longer has any of those
facilities it is unlikely that we will
get a facility because regions don't
need that many of them and
um
and there are others in the new in the
New England or the northeastern region
that um horse owners have and horse pony
mule owners have access to so
um
uh so we don't really need to have the
uh regulations for one of these
facilities since we're not going to have
we don't have one and we won't have one
at any point in the foreseeable future
uh there is also a a
um
dedicated fund which uh provided the
money for dealing with those facilities
and that fund is also uh being removed
needs to be removed from law so
um
that is basically what this bill does
and I'm happy to take brief questions
but I will probably pass most of them on
to the commissioner or to the State Vet
thank you representative Bixby do I see
any questions for representative Bixby
seeing none
uh thank you for your introduction and
testimony to this bill
thank you and I would like to Now call
uh Steve Crawford from Department of
Agriculture
good morning Madam chair good morning
committee good morning Steve Crawford
State veterinarian New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture and thank you
representative Bixby for bringing this
forward for us uh Department supports uh
all three sections being repealed
um
as you heard the veterinary board was
moved from from our department to oplc
several years ago and runs more
efficiently there than it did with us we
never had the bodies to do it
uh the two pieces regarding cem so cem
is an internationally regulated disease
any animals coming in from cem-positive
countries would have to go to a
quarantine station for 28 days before
being released
we had have had two of these
historically in the state the most
recent closed about 15 years ago and so
this has been in statute and we maintain
a dedicated fund because we had to
collect fees from them uh
there are two active cem facilities in
Rhode Island and one in Newburgh New
York about four hours away so three
opportunities within about four hours
for internationally moved horses the two
in Rhode Island always almost always
have capacity so there is room in New
England if people wanted to Avail
themselves of this I don't think it's
necessary anymore for the Department to
maintain that bit of Statute or a
dedicated fund that we never touch
with that I'll have to answer questions
thank you are there any questions
representative Murray
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question sure so
results of Coggins tests do they still
come to you with any information or
regarding cem uh for the quarantine
results
for international travel or Interstate
travel so yeah so the Coggins test is
for equine infectious anemia and this is
for cem so two different diseases the
cem test results
we we wouldn't get and we don't get
because we don't have a quarantine
facility all of the Coggins tester eia
tests both for horses from New Hampshire
leaving here
well I assume say both so for horses
from New Hampshire leaving here we get
those for horses from other states
coming here we get those and then any
for horses tested at our New Hampshire
veterinary Diagnostic lab regardless of
whether or not they're coming or going
from New Hampshire we get those two so
we see 16 000 some results a year
follow what
relative then to the cem test results if
there is a question or a need would you
then refer them just back to the office
of the professional relationship or some
other facility
so if um and I'm going to try and
rephrase your question to make sure I
understand it
so if a horse owner contacted us
interested in cem quarantine where would
we send them okay correct thank you got
it sure so cem oversight is a joint
State and federally managed program we
would likely if they wanted a facility
name we'd refer them to one of the two
in Rhode Island if they wanted had
questions about where
or details we'd refer them to USDA
sure
um I see a question from representative
smart
I think so thank you madam chair
um
I'm wondering about uh when I had horses
if I was going to show or anything I had
to test them before they went before
they left my property
do we not test horses that are coming
from overseas before they come rather
than bringing the disease and even
though it's quarantined
there's only so much quarantine you can
do you can't stop flies you can't stop
mosquitoes so what what
do we not do that I guess is my question
and why uh
I don't know is the short answer because
I haven't kept up on cem regulations
because we haven't had the facility in a
long time
yes there is an awful lot of
pre-movement testing required to enter
the United States but these are federal
regulations for importation into the
country
and I'm not sure why they don't require
this testing but they do require other
testing before coming in
so they so these are CM facilities are
jointly federally and state managed so
USDA has to be involved in that
management
for to your example for horses leaving
your farm to go to a show or across
state lines those still have to be
generally Coggins tested and other stuff
before they would leave your farm
probably some politics playing into why
some some diseases are required before
and some after entry for testing but I
don't know
it doesn't look like you're I'm happy to
try and dig up more for you but I just
don't know unfortunately sure
and I have a question
um so we have a cem fund now is there
any funds is there any money in it and
if not if there is what happens to it if
there is not the fund just goes away
correct with this Bill yes
um yes there is money in it because we
have to maintain a dollar to keep an
account open I believe there's a dollar
in it but I don't know that now it's
it's nominal the money that's in it
um what happens to that money I would
defer to the commission about my guess
it would probably go back to the general
fund thank you Jordan
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much I
appreciate your testimony this morning
happy to do it uh we have no other pink
cards is there anybody else who wishes
to speak on this uh on this bill hb138
nope seeing none I will close the
hearing on this Bill thank you
yeah
thank you okay
all right
um
we're just shy of a minute here
take our breath for uh
for our next hearing
well this is the last
what do we do with these women that's
when we start
um
forgot okay
my apologies I uh I did not receive the
blue sheets for uh the two bills that we
had heard this morning uh for HB 221
there was one pro
no cons listed on the blue sheet for
hb138 we had one pro and no cons
all right
it is 10 30. we are right on schedule
and I would like to now open a hearing
excuse me open the hearing for hb152
relative to soil and plant additives
and our person to introduce this bill
again is representative Bixby
thank you madam chair
um and for the record I should have said
this before the other two and I'd just
remembering now I'm representative Peter
Bixby representing Dover New Hampshire
uh or a fraction thereof and
um
so HP 152 is a result of a study
committee a study committee last term
looking at RSA chapter 431 soil uh which
covers soil conditioners and I sponsored
the study committee bill because uh I
previously had a experience uh looking
at it when I was doing
um working on a couple of other bills
and I noticed that there were some
potential problems with the chapter and
one of the things that we do
um
as as part of our committee is we will
occasionally review chapters of law that
haven't been dealt with for a while to
make sure that everything is up to date
and still working uh and usually we find
a few things that aren't up to date or
aren't working and uh then we put in
legislation to fix it and that that's
what this bill is
um and we identified
um several
categories of issues one has has to do
with essentially nuts and bolts issue
which is issues which is this bill
um there's another bill that has to do
with uh the way that
um
uh the way that uh some of the funds are
handled uh uh the fees the fee revenues
are handled and we'll be hearing that
probably next week uh and there's also
another bill that has to do with some uh
I.T weaknesses that were uh brought up
in our hearings that uh and
um
how to handle uh data issues and uh
that's going to be appearing at the in
in Eda e DNA tomorrow uh but this bill
is basically just a nuts and bolts bill
so
director Wyman from the Department of
Agriculture was very helpful in
explaining how a lot of labeling and
definitions used in this chapter are
drawn from recommendations from the
American the association of American
Plant Food control officials
um or APCO
that's a National Organization that
creates model definitions and rules so
that all states could basically be on
the same playing field uh when they're
defining uh requirements for labeling
and content of uh of plant food
materials uh fertilizers lime Etc
um
and while many of the definitions uh in
the chapter we were happy to learn are
in fact still consistent with everything
that Africa suggests uh the chapter
title soil conditioners didn't have a
standard definition and
um it is also not defined in the chapter
uh the way that this term is used in the
in practice is not really consistent
with what the chapter covers uh uh and
it's much narrower than what the chapter
covers so our first recommendation was
is to re retitle the chapter
to soil and plant additives and then put
a definition into the uh at the
beginning of the chapter defining what
we mean by that and the definition that
we
um propose
encompasses both what the chapter
currently covers and allows for the
possibility of laws relating to similar
uh substances to be added in the future
so that uh if when OLS is looking for a
place to put uh some sort of new plant
or at or soil additive uh into law uh
they will say oh this is the right
chapter to do that
um
another issue we identified was related
to the tonnage reports that fertilizer
manufactures and Distributors need to
file twice a year there's a fee that is
based on the number of tons that uh
fertilizer on distributor sells in a
year and uh they're supposed to every
six months provide a report on how much
they sold and then pay a fee which is a
pretty small fee uh on that uh on what
they sell
um and uh there's a penalty if they fail
to submit that report or fail to
resubmit the payment and the penalty is
so small that it probably is would take
more paperwork to actually submit the
report than uh the the paperwork would
cost more to submit than the penalty so
um what this amendment does is it allows
the commissioner to set the pen penalty
and rules so that it can be kept up to
date and
provide a little bit more incentive for
um for the Distributors to actually
um
uh submit their reports uh the next
issue issue has to do with penalties
when a producer sells a product that
doesn't meet the label description or
the amount description which is referred
to as a deficiency
so essentially this is this is a
situation where a customer is getting
shortchanged because what's being sold
in the bag or in the uh in the truckload
isn't consistent with what they're being
told is there
and these penalties are paid to the
customer who has been shortchanged but
current law says this remedy is only
available to a customer who is purchased
a ton or more and we felt that uh it was
really be appropriate for anyone who was
shortchanged to be able to be able to
get this remedy so
um that's basically what this we just
eliminate the line that says uh it has
to be a ton or more
uh
and there was also an issue with how the
penalty would be calculated the current
system requires the department to uh do
a survey of fertilizer manufacturers to
figure out what the average cost for
each individual component of the
fertilizer is and then put together a uh
a fee a a price schedule and then
publish that schedule and in order to
publish the schedule it has to go
through the Joint Commission committee
on legislative rules uh and uh that
means that by the time that the price
schedule has been published it is often
out of date uh not only is it that but
publishing the schedule is kind of a
silly amount of busy work
so
um what we decided was that the fairest
and quickest method of determining the
value uh that would that would be used
to figure out the penalty would be to
actually look at the invoiced price that
of the material that uh was deficient
and the final issue in the bill deals
with a paragraph that should have been
written with a sunset Clause back in
2013 but wasn't uh and so uh the statute
dealing with turf fertilizer standards
was passed in 2013 and uh it said so
turf fertilizer uh from that point on
had to have could only have a certain
maximum amount of different nutrients in
it and the idea is that you want to
minimize you want to restrict the number
the amount of nutrients in turf
fertilizer to restrict runoff that would
get into waterways uh so
um
so we we passed the law uh specifying
maximum amounts of nutrients and turf
fertilizers however uh there were some
retailers who still have bags of the old
fertilizer on the shelves are going into
2014 when the bill took effect and we
didn't want to penalize the retailers
who still had bags of it on their
shelves and if they still have bags at
the top of their shelves that's a
different problem so
um
so we can pretty be pretty sure that
stock is completely depleted now and we
don't need this this paragraph in law
anymore and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you representative Bixby do we
have questions from the committee
representative Knapp
thank you madam chair and maybe this is
a question for the commissioner but um
is it is it common practice to have the
Departments set feed the fee schedule or
more common to have it within the RSA
it's uh so it depends on the particular
situation and uh in when it's a
relatively small fee then it is often
set by the set by a department uh any
fee that is set by Department in rules
has to be approved by the joint
committee on legislative Administration
uh which and what that commonly called
gel car and what gel car does is it
basically looks at rules that are
promulgated by departments and uh before
they get and before they can be you know
fully implemented gel car has to say yes
this rule is consistent with the
legislative intent of the statutes so
um basically any time of any time a fee
is set in rule it does have legislative
oversight in order to make sure that it
is an appropriate fee
thank you
um I have a question about
uh the section three
uh line 19.
it says that established by the
commissioner in rules adopted pursuant
to RSA 541-a
541-a has got many many sections to it
did you want to
refer to any particular
section or is this just the entire
administrative procedure act that you're
referring to okay so that is pretty much
boilerplate language for any time that
you're asking for something to be a
department to be able to establish rules
uh what what RSA 541a as a whole does is
it uh basically sets lays the ground
rules for uh for right for departments
writing rules so
um so so basically any part of 541a that
is relevant to setting these rules
should be needs to be
um they need to be consistent with that
thank you for that explanation
representative Murray
you madam chair for taking my question I
think this question might
I might know the answer uh that's fine
so if you you had mentioned that the
position of the fertilizers
so my question would be that in the
event that I'm curious to know if there
is a requirement to list what is in the
fertilizer that could be potential
contaminants like pfas or anything else
and if so are those listed on
bags of fertilizer currently
uh I think that I'm I'm gonna guess that
director Wyman is going to be coming up
to uh uh either director Wyman or the or
the commissioner and uh he can probably
ask answer that more specifically I know
that the answer for for pesticides is
they don't need to be declared but I
don't know uh what what the inert
ingredient requirements are in
fertilizer
thank you thank you
thank you representative Bixby I do I
see any other questions no and I do not
have any other pink cards so uh okay we
have one
can I say
thank you and I need the Blue Shield
so I have here on Deck uh Alan Wyman
I invite you up to uh
to speak on this bill hb152
thank you my name is Alan Wyman I am the
director of regulatory Services uh under
which this bill would be relevant and
specific to the question there is no uh
requirement to list uh
contaminants such as pfaster lead or
anything of that nature
let me see
okay any other questions to
Mr Wyman from the committee
being none thank you very much
and I have no more pink cards for a
testimony for this bill if anybody else
is interested in speaking
okay
we have
um
on our blue sheet we have one person who
is written against this legislation and
we had one person who submitted
testimony online or or not submitted
testimony but signed up online to
support this bill
and with that I will close the hearing
on
HP 152.
and we are
15 minutes ahead of schedule so I'm
going to call a break a little recess
for the committee and we will get back
at 11 o'clock to hear the next bill hb79
okay everybody it is now 11 o'clock
and I am going to open up the hearing
for HB 79
and I will introduce representative
Aiken Ankerberg for uh him to introduce
this bill to us
good morning representative Ankerberg
good morning Madam chair
for the record in Ankerberg I represent
Stratford District 10. that's the lovely
people in the Lilac City of Rochester
um so I'm here this morning to present
House Bill 79 as you see I've handed out
amendments to that bill which I'm hoping
you'll consider and what this amendment
does is actually strip out the language
of the bill
and go towards the intent of what we
were trying to do here which dealt with
the section that you'll see stripped out
and constituent brought this to my
attention some ambiguous language in in
this section referring to reasonable
hours
so I asked uh commissioner Jasper if he
would be willing to Define that in
statute what reasonable hours are and he
came he came back to me and said why
don't we just eliminate that section
because the administrative rules with
fisma actually cover this so this this
should be a fairly
um
simple change I believe the department
is in agreement on that so
I hope you will consider the amendment
thank you representative Ankerberg
anybody have questions for
representative Ankerberg on this
I have a question and I'd like to know
um how
how did this this issue come up I mean
you said you had a constituent who yes
who got in touch with you yeah just give
us a little background about why all of
a sudden this was to be well I I the uh
my constituent who's here in the room he
had brought this to my attention about
you know this section in here relating
to reasonable hours of inspection and
again what's reasonable to you may not
be reasonable to me
um you know so wherever possible I think
it's it's incumbent on us to clarify the
scope of what producers can expect
whether they're transporting storing
selling any product right and so they
they should have clear guidelines as to
know what their what the hours and scope
of any investigation would be thank you
and are you you mentioned the hours were
already specified in rules somewhere
else uh that that's what the
commissioner has told me yes so it's
already in statute
um so and as he has related to me this
is a his enforcement arm is a five day a
week operation uh I I we don't see a
we don't see any history of abuse of
this uh we don't
um we don't anticipate that there there
would be it's just a simple matter of
trying to clarify what reasonable hours
were so thank you deference to that we
have agreed to just strip out this
section and just
okay thank you representative Crichton
has a question for you representative
thank you so much uh thank you madam
chair uh but as I look at the amendment
there's a sentence in the bill that says
he or she shall have power in person
or by his Deputy agent to open any box
Barrel or any other container now that
comes out that sentence also comes out
in the amendment yes be thank you for
the question yes that is already
referred to in the the rules that the
commissioner operates under so that's
already in there as well yes so this is
just taking out of out of this statute
and
leaving that out and it because it
already appears in another place
under the fisma rules thank you the
commissioner could probably testify to
that
okay uh representative NAB
thank you madam chair um I just wonder
maybe this is a question for the
commissioner if this if similar language
is in place under all of these
regulations and where you draw the line
at not needing any of this guideline
information as to access and ability to
to yeah thank you for the question uh we
had just gone over that
um and the commissioner had mentioned to
me that there may be some need to go
through all of these uh just to make
sure that they're
um you know the same scope
so I I can't speak to the fisma uh
regulations that that he operates under
I was just dealing with this particular
section the the commissioner has
mentioned to me that he's in agreement
and my constituent's in agreement so I
think we found a reasonable compromise
here thank you
representative Howard
thank you madam chairman
um so
uh and this sort of a follow-up to the
question before
um
of Representative Creighton
um it seems like you're stripping all of
these things away and it would be I
think it would be if you could give us
the the place that we can find the the
the
Department's empowerment to open the box
to you know to take the evidence to you
know all the provisions inside that are
being crossed out here but because it
seems to me that
um
the the hours what seem to be the main
complaint and why did why strip away all
the other powers
again my understanding is that these are
redundant this is a redundant section
uh to the authority the commissioner
already has
follow-up yeah
thank you madam chairman so um could we
could we get a reference to where
um I I don't have that I don't have
copies of that now but I've certainly be
willing to provide that to the committee
before the executive session
okay seeing no other questions for
representative Ankerberg
I would take this opportunity to call uh
thank you thank you I would take this
opportunity to call Stephen nass up to
speak on this
one red button I go oh sorry about that
first time up here testifying on
anything uh but you'll see me more in
the future I think but uh yeah welcome
I'm thank you uh good morning uh Stephen
nass I'm a resident of Milton I'm a
restaurant owner I also have a trade
Association of farmers restaurant tours
and anybody in the food industry that's
looking for deregulation and a little
more freedom
um I did put this uh Bill forward with
uh Aiden's help here uh I'm looking for
ways in which we can scale back uh some
of the uh
uh regulation a good opportunity here
um and I just wanted to yeah clarify
that I am in uh support of this
compromise with him and uh
yeah I think it'd be a good one for uh
us to put forward that's about it
thank you any questions for Mr Nass
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and thank you for coming in today
and I would like now to invite
commissioner Jasper up Jasper pardon me
Jasper to come and speak on behalf of
hb79
thank you madam
members of the committee I'm still Sean
Jasper and I'm still the commissioner
um
so
apparently we had a little
it's just slight breakdown in
Communications
products safety and I would call your
attention it's chapter
426 a and the rules are
I don't want to if you go to the
department website and you go to rules
under the commissioner you can find find
the rules adopted but the law is um
specific again two reasonable hours
we're in uh you know an eight to four
four operation actually and so those
would be the reasonable times however
I do have the authority under this
statute if there is an eminent threat to
Public Safety
to go in at other other times
um and that's under the the fisma rule I
frankly I I don't have a problem I don't
believe I've just got to double check
um with our attorney from the doj but I
think that the amendment is fine
frankly this whole chapter
ought to be looked at and it might be a
better idea and more productive to
actually look at how
um 34 and 26a fit together because there
is an awful lot of overlap there we
really when we adopted fisma that really
wasn't looked at and there's potentially
some confusion some redundancy and
pretend potentially some conflicts in
there I haven't had time to look at it
either because what we used really is in
uh
in 426 the I think it's 426. um just had
that there
fisma is where we uh yeah my phone's
timed out already
um
so you know we really need need to look
at this and see what it is but you know
believe me I don't I'm not going to pay
anybody never have paid anybody overtime
just to go out and look at Apple
someplace
um so that hasn't been a problem you
know again I think there's perception
because I can do it at reasonable times
but those are the only times that are
reasonable to us is during normal
working hours for the department
and the rest of it you know the rules
um on the Apple specifically expired I
have no intention to bring those back
because
they um
are covered under fisma so that's why I
think we want to be productive we could
spend some time
comparing those two chapters and and
trying to figure out how they've better
fit together because they probably don't
work very well for the department or for
anybody right now the way they are
thank you
um representative Bixby yes thank you
for taking my question so
um
it do you think that it might actually
make more sense rather than striking out
this one
um one paragraph or part of this one
paragraph to maybe convert this bill
into a study committee for the entire
chapter
that would be my recommendation yes
thank you
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my questions
so I guess that was sort of the the
question
the question I had but also it sounded
like this specific bill was still
leaving in and I'm referring to both the
underlying bill and the amendment I
suppose
um that it was allowing rule making
authority to still stay in there and so
I guess my question was at what point
does fisma take over versus the
rulemaking and so I that was the
question I had well we do have rules
under fisma but they're specific to 420
six I didn't have a chance to really
look at this I mean because we have
really just been operating under under
fisma for most of these things there may
be sections in here
uh dealing with honey and maple that may
need to be left in but I but I think we
need to separate the wheat from the
chaff here and figure out you know what
belongs here what belongs in in 426 and
I just simply you know we move from one
thing to another record pace and as I
started to look at at things after my
conversations
representative Ankerberg uh it occurred
to me that probably
um
should look at this a little in a little
bit more more in depth certainly nothing
that is being proposed to being stricken
out if we don't do that right now
um
it's not something we're doing anyhow we
did go in in conjunction with HHS they
identified listeria into packing
facilities last year of apples and we
went in
um and did inspections and did do stop
it sale orders on
um on apples but that was strictly a
defismal
representative knabb
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner
um I just wonder if you view this as
getting rid of a redundancy or as
deregulation because we've sort of been
given two different narratives here I I
think this the sponsor and certainly the
gentleman who requested this are looking
at it as deregulation
as I explained to the representative
that is not possible because if in fact
you said okay we don't want to do any of
this and we're going to repeal chapter
426 in and give fisma back to the
government
um all everything there would still take
place strictly under Federal enforcement
and I would challenge you to find me one
single Farm in the state of New
Hampshire that wants the USDA in versus
New Hampshire Department of AG markets
and food
because if you can I'd like to have that
conversation
um because I think we have two totally
different approaches
our approach in the department is to
work with the farmers to make things
safe for everyone and I think the USDA
tends to come down with a little bit
more of an Iron Fist and
um we're we're working and we work with
of course Cooperative Extension to do
the education that's necessary to make
sure that things are going right so you
can't do away with what people are are
suggesting they will exist it's just
under
federal or state Authority and I'll go
with State any day of the week
and I would have said that before I was
commissioner too
representative Murray you have a
question
I'm sure commissioner
commissioner the response by HHS was
sort of
um maybe some testing of the apples that
revealed this certain listeria and in
which case it sounds like fisma kicked
in and was an emergency sort of
situation yeah well and we
still did everything within normal
working hours so
and this is this is the you know we're
the Department of Agriculture markets
and Foods except for Foods in certain
place
ultimately
I believe that we should all be under
one Authority and I think that should be
the Department of Agriculture
um HHS is already 50 of the government
and I think that they probably view the
food part of it as somewhat of a
stepchild and there are inherent
conflicts by having two different
authorities sort of
well we're doing this when it's in the
field and in the packing house and
you're doing this once it gets to the
the grocery stores or to the restaurants
and that doesn't make a lot of sense to
me that there ought to be a process that
is uh smooth smooth um flowing but we
did work well together they tested the
apples on the store shelves found
contamination in the packaged apples in
the stores we went back to the source
found the contamination
um
in the packing facilities and worked
with the the Packers to uh to change
that in one case it resulted in a whole
new packing line because they were
operating a
um
packing line that was probably new in
the 1950s maybe in the 1940s and there
was absolutely no way to bring it up to
uh modern standards although I let them
make that determination on their own I
had some in my department that that said
you're going to replace that line and
you're never going to use it again and I
said no I'm going to give them the
opportunity to show us whether or not
that can be brought up to current
standards they came to their own
conclusion that it could not and replace
the line which I think makes them feel a
lot better than me just saying Thou
shalt do this
and that's not the way I like to operate
thank you
representative Crichton
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner
um so just to make sure I understand
what you're saying you support this bill
as is as a first step or a bite at the
Apple if you will I am not sure because
I don't know what I don't know my intent
last week was to send it over to uh the
attorney our attorney at the doj to make
sure I wasn't missing something
I think I'm okay with it okay but
um I'm I'm not sure because I don't want
to get myself in trouble by having
missed some legal
piece of it but I think
the more effective thing to do is to
look at how
426 and 434
can work together and be
come a very clear set of of laws and
rules rather than just what we overlaid
fisma and you know
because some of the language is
identical on this you know stop sale I
have authority under both I don't need
Authority in two places and you know
things like that
and for a follow-up man yes the uh and
so given that comparison between 434 and
do you need a study committee to do that
or do you just do that as a matter of
course because
well in your job jar
think that
you know we could do that on our own I'm
not sure we'll get to that sometimes it
takes a little legislative initiative a
subcommittee to do a study to look at it
the other thing that that does is makes
everybody comfortable with what I what
I'm doing if I came back and had just
done it myself
you'd all say oh what's that bureaucrat
up to
you know whereas if you're part of the
process then you can explain to the rest
of the the committee and being sure that
this isn't a bureaucratic maneuver to
get more Authority
um because let's face it
people always feel that that's what
departments do and
sometimes that's correct thank you
representative Bixby
thank you for taking my question if
um if we wanted to turn this into a
study committee would you be willing to
help us
um sort of create list the list the
action items that we'd need to include
in order to make sure that we're
studying everything that needs to be
studied
I think you know the answer to that
representative Bixby of course I would
thank you
representative Murray I'm sorry you're
next
oh okay representative Compton I'm sorry
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um
I am happy to hear that uh you're would
like this as a study committee
um
and just uh for reference would you say
that study committees uh also help
um weed out uh wording and uh
RS in the rsas that is no longer needed
and bring us up to date into the 21st
century would you say that is what a
study committee could do I would
certainly agree with you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair for taking my question
um and if this were to go to a study
committee and we are still waiting a
reply from the doj it would we be
expecting that prior to it going to a
study committee or could you elaborate
somewhat on that I I frankly if that's
where the committee is leaning to to
study it I would rather not waste the
doj's time on spending the time looking
into that I think it could be better
that time because we you know we have a
very limited amount of uh time we get
from the doj and it can take some time
so
you know as soon as as possible if the
you know if you could get a sense of the
committee if that's where they were
going then we could sort of back off and
um look at the ex use
um the resources more wisely I think
for the clarification
representative Potenza
so just to clarify
fisma's not going anywhere of course so
ah having the state
have whatever Authority underneath there
that's just basically creating a love
um
kind of a layer so then fisma's not in
control in a sense or the federal
government's not in control and then
we're still in control on the state side
we still have to do the reporting or
whatever is necessary to fisma correct
yes
um in fisma so everyone knows is paid
for 100 percent
by the federal government
in our statutes very clear that if they
stop paying 100 of fisma
um
then we don't do that and it reverts the
federal government
that being said even if there are some
things in
434 that we would say Well if you know
if we're not doing fisma we ought to be
doing them I'd view that as redundancy
and so I don't think they need to be in
State Statute if fism is going to do
them under regardless of whose authority
they're under
so I really I don't believe in
redundancy and in statute
um as long as somebody has that
Authority and I can't imagine that the
feds since they've started this are
going to uh stop stop funding it on the
state level because obviously some of
what is is going on
is going to go on with with State and
inspectors
just as a course of daily
um operations but right now we have two
part-time inspectors
who are doing the fisma inspections we
just started as a matter of fact last
Friday
the person who's doing the
administrative work and we'll be doing
we'll be learning and doing some
inspections but that's the entire fisma
staff 100 paid for except of course we
Supply the office space but they supply
all they buy the furniture they pay for
the desks they you know everything
it's covered
thank you any other questions for the
commissioner
seeing none thank you for your testimony
my pleasure
and I'd just like to remind members part
of the Gen Court website includes a tab
for administrative rules so if you want
to look up any rules from any of the
Departments it is on our website
um
are there any I don't have any other
pink cards for this particular Bill are
there any other folks that would like to
testify either for or against
seeing none I would say uh we have on
our blue sheet three people who signed
up in favor of HB 79
and online we had one in favor and one
against
so with that I will close the hearing on
HB 79 and we have a few minutes of break
until 11 30 for our next bill
128.
people
start
Ed yeah
well see if we didn't know that you know
the first section of that
okay
um I'm gonna call the committee back and
we are going to open up the hearing for
HB 128 FN
and to introduce this Bill Let's see we
have
um
representative Ankerberg
welcome back
thank you madam chair again for the
record I am a nankerberg I represent
Stratford 10 which is the city of
Rochester and I'm here to introduce
house bill 128. so as you'll see I
handed out another amendment for 128.
um and what this does is strip out the
language of the underlying bill
and going towards the intent of the
original bill which was to
have the state be in charge of the
licensing of seed for sale after talking
to the director director Wyman
we came to a realization that that is a
unworkable system in large part because
that would lead to New Hampshire being a
Dumping Ground of
junk seed so obviously nobody wants to
do that
the the reasoning behind the bill was
throughout the pandemic we've seen and
we still see in you know a large part
with eggs other products you know
everybody's been to the grocery store so
what we're talking about here is food
resiliency
this this is simply a way for hobby
Farmers to
um you know produce more seed possibly
sell it yeah I don't know if any of you
folks are involved with the seed trading
groups in your community I bought a
greenhouse a couple years ago and have
gotten involved with that I know the I
know the the chairwoman here um is a
very active farmer so I try and pick her
brain every once in a while about you
know how to grow some of these different
things but um with with so many other
folks going down this path of trying to
produce more and more
um of their own vegetables and things I
thought it was appropriate to sort of
bump up what an individual might be
expected to be able to produce
um so you know obviously in my little
Greenhouse I'm not going to be able to
produce 50 pounds of seed but some of
these smaller Farms some of these
operations may be able to have that if
they're trading sort of larger
quantities you know in the pounds
um I I thought it was appropriate
um that the state be seen is is bumping
up that amount from the current level of
25 pounds uh per year per individual
that they could sell up and just double
that up to 50 pounds in my talks with
the commissioner and director Wyman they
said that this this is not something
that they're even currently enforcing at
all so I think this is more of just a
message to the the citizenry that we we
are open as a state to you you know
providing that buffer for your family in
order to produce these seeds and if you
have a surplus then of course you'd be
able to sell up to 50 pounds a year so
that's the scope of the
thank you representative Ankerberg
question representative Murray
I'm chair um thank you for taking
particular delineating between somebody
simply trading another Farmer for things
or physically selling for profit so can
you elaborate on yourself thank you for
the question
um so yes of course like seed trading is
um it has become something
that is sort of evoke right now uh but
but my thinking was that we're not we're
not talking obviously people selling in
stores and things but we want to keep it
open uh what I was thinking is more of a
farmer's market type
type setting so if somebody had little
packets of seeds say you know but they
would get up to that
um they could get up to over the 25
pound limit now you know but again if
you just for scale I don't know if if
you have a yard at home right so every
year my plow guy rips up you know all my
grass along the driveway and you know I
have to fill that in well I go to the
store and I buy a bag of seed right so
usually that's you know 40 50 pounds you
know I have chickens again that'd be a
50 pound bag right so we're talking you
know 50 pounds it's not something you'd
be able to seed you know a large
agricultural operation with we're
talking about home
um you know providing that buffer for
families to be able to produce their
their own seeds and things and if you
don't have experience in doing that it
can be difficult at first to harvest the
seeds because you'll have a very low
success rate of them growing so if you
could get them if I could get them from
chairwoman Aaron who I know knows what
she's doing and harvesting them
um you know and she could offer me some
you know whatever whatever the the case
may be there that that provides me with
a little more Comfort if I'm going to be
planting those and expecting to to
harvest them so
representative
thank you madam chair thank you
representative uh for taking my question
um now how would we and I understand
that 50 pounds is not a lot
but
um and they're currently nothing's being
enforced but we are have to be conscious
also of any noxious seeds that come into
these packets and how that will affect
the uh State as a whole
uh what would you say to that
oh thank you for the question I I my
response to that would be what what are
we doing now right
um so if it was the the committee's wish
I mean you could certainly amend that to
say in in-state sales and then you're
we're not Crossing Lines I mean what
would we have for an invasive species
that wasn't already being harvested and
cultivated here right so I mean I I
don't know that anybody is going to be
harvesting you know Japanese not weed
and be selling that in their Community
to you know to take take over
um so I mean realistically we'd be
talking about more you know Tomatoes
carrot you know things things like that
representative Bixby
okay so
um
a couple of uh just just so that you're
aware
um I was on the committee when we set
the limit at 25 and we set that limit
because we
um
thought that 25 was an awful lot of
seeds and
um and I just wanted to make sure that
you're aware that so are you aware that
this is not dealing with grass seed but
only fruit flour and vegetable seeds yes
okay and uh do you know about how many
seed tomato seeds you get in a pound
well thank you for the question I I
don't know that that's relevant uh well
it I think if we're setting a limit for
the number for how many how much we're
selling I think it is relevant to be
aware that
um there are an awful lot of that
for the I'm just thinking about scale
here and I'm wondering if
um there's really any point in
in changing our current 25 pounds
because I think uh
I I'm I'm
not entirely sure
um well I guess maybe I should rephrase
this question because I'm I'm getting in
I'm running into the danger of making a
comment as opposed to asking a question
but
um have you heard of any instances where
someone in New Hampshire was trying to
sell seed of vegetables or fruits or
flowers and ran up against this limit
I I have not heard of any any case
thereof but again having a limit in
statute means that somebody would have
to be cognizant of that right so that
could actually serve as a Prohibition a
self-imposed Prohibition on somebody
from harvesting that amount of seed
okay thank you
representative
thank you madam chairman thank you for
representative for taking my question uh
somewhat similar I suppose to
representative bixby's questioner where
I think he was going in part uh so in
the absence of evidence of a need to
make this change and knowing as as you
said that it isn't being enforced at the
moment is this uh kind of a classic
example of a solution in search of a
problem
I thank you for the question I I would
say that this is this is a compromise
seeking to expand or move the goal post
further out in the with the reasoning
and the rationale that somebody may wish
to encroach on that 25 pound number and
if they are say one pound over we would
say that you would be allowed to sell
that seed I I don't know that we we have
seen evidence either way of it being
beneficial or a problem
right so so I don't know that 26 pounds
is is necessarily a negative in regards
to a 25 pound or 50 pound limit I I
don't understand why that would be
yes sir thank you uh well in that case
we're talking about evidence right since
we're talking about changing statutes
shouldn't the requirement for evidence
be on the side of the need for a change
right I hear what you're saying in terms
of we don't have evidence either way but
with a piece of legislation the burden
is on the proposer to present evidence
that there is reason to change the
current statute
yes I I would thank you for that and I
my position on on the bill and and with
these ideas is that what what I am going
from is is past experience recent
experience going through the pandemic
and going to grocery stores and things
and not being able to find certain
products certain vegetables and so with
with that in mind what we want what I
was thinking is that this this serves as
a hedge against that against uh
consumers not being able to have those
products because if the local
supermarket doesn't have those a local
grower may be able to have like a crop
of that available at a farmer's market
type setting where the consumer could
get that product whereas the the larger
Supermarket may not be able to obtain
those products
thank you
thank you and um representative Murray
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um I do have a I I'm curious to know
about the intersection and do you know
about the intersection of potential
cross-contamination like save garlic
mustard got into the seed packet or
something of that nature and you had 50
pounds of of seeds that were being
self-sourced or
um
do you find any concern for the invasive
species of plants that we are we are we
do have
um
concern for certain species you
mentioned not weeds so I'm just curious
if you yes thank you for the question uh
my understanding in in a larger setting
is I know there's been
um some complaints among genetically
modified seeds and things like that are
actually being produced as hybrids and
things going into you know somebody
else's another Farmer's property and
then then the farmers claiming you know
that you you've now infringed on my my
product but again that that could be as
simple as one seed right so that could
be picked up by a bird dropped over on
somebody else's property so I mean I I
don't know the difference even between a
pound 50 pounds or a Single Seed because
the that possibility still exists and I
mean that that possibility exists in
nature as it is now so I I'm not sure
that you know with a fear of of a
natural cause right I mean we've all
seen the dandelions right the the little
uh white things like flying through the
air here in springtime right so we know
that that that that cross pollination
thing that happens in in neighborhoods
in a you know in our state already so I
again I I think it's it's best to just
think of the scope of this and and what
the the intent is I mean I I'm talking
about tomatoes not Japanese not weed
right so or something similar
thank you
any other questions from the committee
for representative ankenberg
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony and I call Alan Wyman from
Department of Agriculture
foreign
good morning again
press the button there you go thank you
um thank you for having me up here again
my name is Al Wyman in this capacity I'm
acting as a New Hampshire seed law
enforcement officer I work for the
division of regulatory Services
Department of
Agriculture markets and food
as I understand the when I was first
given a copy of the bill I think is
significantly different than what we're
speaking about now if I understand and
for clarity I'm speaking to the change
only of 25 to 50 pounds in that RSA
um I can't speak either way uh as to
whether I oppose it do not oppose as as
you guys I think already know at this
point it's it's one of the national
programs it's put out by Ross ASCO
through through Russell which is the
uniform State legislation uh I it's it's
in heart it's heartening to know there
was an individual here who who
understands why the 25 pounds were put
in place to begin with I do not and
typically what I would do in a situation
like this is contact other state law
enforcement officers as well as ASCO and
the president there in in their staff to
to see that this isn't uh gonna be
friction with other state laws because
what we don't want to do is is uh cost
manufacturer to then have to a relative
I can't speak relative to the the uh
well
this really is associated with noxious
weeds invasive species and plant variety
protection act right now the larger
companies have the capability and
knowledge as to what they should and
shouldn't pass small farmers maybe they
do maybe they don't other states they'll
they track down to eight ounces and the
reason is
um
you have 50 pounds of eight ounce
packets that people are trading at
whether it's a farmer's market or
selling I I believe this has to do with
sales and not trades I don't know
but once you start uh trading eight
ounce packets up to 50 pounds if if
there's something in that lot that's
been distributed in that fashion now
it's distributed across the whole state
potentially so uh somebody brought that
up SE one thing I can think off the top
of my head that you just want to be
aware of that you know a 50 pound
distribution of carrot seeds for
instance are going to be significantly
different than a 50 pound distribution
of beans via eight ounce packages right
or however it gets done and and I only
point out eight ounce because that's how
it is in another state that I saw was
trying to review for the other uh
original bill
I have no more to to offer at this point
any questions from the committee
representative Bixby uh could you just
spell out what ASCO stands for
absolutely
State seed
uh certification officials
Association of State seed certification
officials I'm fairly certain
okay
and Russell is uh recommended uniform
State seed law
so Association of State seed
certification officials okay I believe
so yes and if you were to Google
assco you would get the exact uh I just
want to caution you that I don't have it
in front of me
okay thank you
any other questions for Mr Wyman I do
have a question
if this was bumped up to 30 pounds would
that be an issue
again without having further discussions
with the other C uh Law Enforcement
Officers throughout the country I I am
reticent to speak to this
okay thank you
representative Bixby uh have you had any
uh Enforcement cases related to this
not specific to the to the pound of seed
no
hold on follow-up have you had
enforcement uh any enforcement uh cases
related to
um distribution of uh seeds on a small
scale as opposed to you know what you
would get from say Burpee or off
Johnny's
typically when that occurs it's because
we've noted a violation either in
labeling or or in date of sales and we
go back to the database to try to figure
out
who the registrant is and that's when we
find out if there is or is not a
registering if we're speaking
specifically to the registration piece
of this
thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this morning thank you and I
call Stephen Nass
to testify on hb128
welcome good morning thanks for having
me back up here again again I'm Stephen
nass I'm restaurant owner and Chef I
also grew up on a very small farm and we
constantly looked for ways for our our
little farm to make money and look for
opportunity and I really think
um with this bill the two things that
you should keep in mind would be
opportunity and resiliency opportunity
in that any time we deregulate or expand
how much product our small farmers in
the state can produce and sell it's
creating more opportunity for them in
ways that are unseen there might be
people out there that would that would
look at selling seeds and collecting
them but they do the math and they say
that 25 pounds is not enough because if
we're talking eight ounces eight ounce
bags that's maybe 50 bags that might not
be enough for them to make it worth
their while versus if we increase the
amount
suddenly it's profitable part of their
business that they can expand on and
then as far as resiliency goes uh the
representative spoke about uh the supply
chain issues that we've had in the past
and we're definitely still ongoing with
those and I think that anything we can
do to make our own State more resilient
and and enable our Farmers to save their
seeds and trade amongst each other and
by trade I mean selling to each other uh
I think is going to be uh
much more beneficial to us in the long
run and it's going to be hard to put
solid numbers on exactly what those
benefits are but uh I think subjectively
going to the stores and going to the
markets we'll see the results of those
things
um
there is a talk about
um this being a solution in search of a
problem and like I said I don't really
see it that way I see this as creating
those opportunities and if we're talking
about enforcement of uh the seed
labeling bills the only concerns I've
seen brought up today
um by the previous speaker uh would be
dealing with the red tape if mislabeling
or confusion about when the seeds were
produced and I think at the end of the
day uh nobody's going to if we're
talking small farmers selling seeds to
each other
um
nobody has a greater uh liability or
desire for the product to be good than
those two farmers and that plays again
into if we're worried about invasive
species these are these are small
farmers selling to each other uh the
state has uh less of
um
a desire for those invasive species to
be spread than uh the concerns that the
farmers themselves are going to be
having so I think to say that uh
to put to uh put these keep DC graduate
regulations around and keep keep them as
expansive as they are
um as opposed to giving the power back
to the farmers themselves uh is a bit of
an absurd statement to me
uh so again I just want you guys to
think about the opportunity that uh
growing the amount of seeds that can be
sailed or sold uh is going to bring to
our state and then again resiliency
amongst our farming community and our
Network thank you
thank you Mr Nas representative Knapp
thank you madam chair um
I have a question sort of about the seed
testing piece because these are nice
stories about people selling seeds to
each other but as anyone here who has a
garden knows if I gave you some tomato
seeds you'll probably get some like
generic grape tomato that doesn't taste
very good so you have a lot of plants
that like really cross-pollinate and
people who grow seeds for those plants
you know they're isolating them they're
not just like pulling tomato seeds out
of their yard so I mean is there a piece
like is there a truth and advertising
piece to seed selling that if I sell you
Tomatoes or pumpkins they're really
going to be what I say they are
I think definitely I mean if you want to
continue selling those seeds again then
you're going to have to be truthful the
first time you do it or we're not going
to you know the second person's not
going to be buying from you again and I
I do think we didn't touch on
um how beneficial it is to be selling
seeds to your neighbors because rather
than buying from these uh big
International companies you're buying
seeds that you know can be grown in your
area because the person you're buying
them from actually grew them in your
area and you're more likely to get the
product that you want
um
representative germanna thank you madam
chair uh and thank you for coming in
today and and talking to us uh so my
question is you know we're talking about
say 25 pounds versus 50 pounds what
evidence we haven't seen any to tell us
why it should be 50 instead of 25 would
it be safe to say that in your opinion
we just shouldn't regulate this at all
and there would be no limit uh and I
mean in my opinion
my personal opinion any sort of
Regulation like this should be desired
by the buyer or the seller and not
imposed on them by the state itself in
advance
um because that strikes me as a law
looking for a problem like you had
spoken a bit about before
um
yeah that's that'd be my personal
opinion
can I ask a follow-up yes sir uh but
wouldn't that end up if we're talking
about and I understand and I appreciate
your argument about increasing
opportunity but then don't we also got
to a point where it overly benefits
large producers of seeds as opposed to
small producers of seeds uh because then
they could produce and sell large
quantities of seeds without having to go
through these regulatory processes and
guarantee the quality of their product
doesn't it in the end then benefit
larger producers if we simply expand
that cap yeah I would see larger
producers have a lot more uh financially
at stake for selling the correct product
that they say is going to be sold so if
they're if a large producer is out there
selling seed that uh is not what they
say that is on the label they're opening
themselves up to lawsuits and also uh
the the customer reviews and the uh
the buying process is going to decrease
for those companies because their
product is unreliable if you bought
seeds from uh if you bought tomato seeds
from a major corporation and you plant
them and either they didn't grow because
they were too old or they were just the
wrong product you're not going back to
them again so they actually they have
their own incentives for making sure
that the product is correct and I don't
see any large seed producer not having
testing done above and beyond
what our state is doing on its own
anyway
thank you
representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking
my question have you or uh the
representative had any conversations
with other stakeholders like the Farm
Bureau to understand how this may impact
organizations such as that
no I have not had any contact with uh
other organizations outside the state my
my focus is on communicating directly
with the local farmers in this state and
and those people uh in my restaurant
it's very farm to table so I interact
with Farmers constantly and we actually
have a monthly meet up for farmers and
homesteaders so I get voice concerns
directly from them
thank you
thank you Mr Nas any other questions
from the committee no thank you
appreciate your testimony and I have one
more pink card from commissioner Jasper
so I'd like to invite you up
and invite your comments
thank you madam chair members of the
committee I didn't have any intent to
testify on this bill
director Wyman covered our concerns
however previous testimony sort of
sparked sparked me to come up here I I
think by the nature of some of the
questions I think the committee does get
this uh issue
but one of the things that was just
um said really sort of got me to
thinking and that was the regulations
should be promulgated and laws should be
promulgated because there's a need by
the the buyers and the and the sellers
to have that we don't know and I would
actually suspect that that is exactly
why this law is in place but there was
no evidence that some legislator just
thought this would be a good idea to do
decades ago so people ought to have the
research before they say that just
because it happened a long time ago
doesn't mean that it wasn't because
there was a problem
so uh
that's sort of I guess offends me as a
former legislator that that's what
legislators spend their time doing is
just looking for a solution to a problem
that doesn't exist I would suggest there
probably was a problem
the other thing that that really got me
thinking is
the previous
individual who testified
isn't a buyer or a seller of seeds
and if there was a need to change this
law
I would have expected to see those small
sellers in here telling us why this
current amount is uh is a problem
representative
director Wyman did indicate that there
are certainly a huge difference between
pounds of
bean seeds and 25 pounds of carrot seed
so if if there was an issue then perhaps
a different category I don't think we
could if if the committee is interested
in bumping this up to to 50 50 pounds
maybe there ought to be a different
category just like we do in pet vending
you know you have a different number for
fish that you sell versus dogs so really
in terms of size it's not dissimilar so
just my thoughts thank you
thank you Mr commissioner any other
questions from the committee
thank you for your time and appreciate
it
I don't see any other pink cards or
folks if anybody is interested in making
further comment please let yourself be
known
seeing none I'm awaiting the blue sheet
we have one person in favor of this
legislation on the blue sheet and online
one in favor and three opposed
so with that I am going to close the
hearing oh sorry
yeah well I think we uh we can talk
about all of the bills at the end of
today and see where everybody is on them
okay thank you
so I'm going to close this hearing on
hb128
and we are going to break for lunch and
we will be back here at one o'clock
difficult
foreign
agriculture committee
all right
I hope everybody had a pleasant lunch
all right uh we are on
HB 369
and let's see here
and we have uh representative McGee here
to introduce this bill HB 369
establishing a task force to provide
energy relief on farms good afternoon
representative good afternoon chairwoman
um Aaron thank you
appreciate you having me here today
I come here today to ask for your
support in passing HB 369 to help New
Hampshire form a sunlit Farm's energy
relief task force to investigate the
potential for funding solar-powered
farming with monies from the inflation
reduction Act
a significant chunk of those federal
dollars are intended to help States
increase Energy Efficiency and convert
to more sustainable energy practices
the idea of focusing on farms came from
one of my constituents Trevor Hardy of
Brookdale Fruit Farms in Hollis New
Hampshire representative Ming and I were
attending an agricultural event at
Woodmont Orchards for legislators when
Hardy a Seventh Generation Hollis farmer
asked why New Hampshire didn't offer tax
credits to Farmers who install solar to
power their Farms
he had a friend who bought a competitive
local Farm Kimball's most of whose land
is located just over the Border in
Massachusetts and that farm came with
tracking solar arrays
and mass also allows net metering
credits so Trevor's complaint was that
uh his fellow farmer and friend had no
electric bill while his utility costs
were quite large and increasing due to
what was happening in the market
uh Kimball's entire Farm operation was
powered by those solar arrays they were
there was a large upfront investment but
they were now yielding ongoing benefits
to the cost of their operation
that stabilized both the business and
meant that prices to Consumers would
also be held stable
um in a time of inflation
so I took my constituents question and
tried to figure out if there was any way
to come up with a bill that could help
him and other New Hampshire farmers who
have slim margins in their businesses
and perform an essential service for New
Hampshire's food economy
uh cut to this fall when a
representative of Senator Shaheen's
office made a presentation to the Energy
Efficiency and sustainable energy board
known as the easy Board of which myself
and the chair of my committee chairman
Vose are members
um speaker appointed members and that
presentation covered high-level
categories of money from the inflation
reduction act that could help States
transition to cleaner energy practices
one of the categories mentioned was
renewable agriculture but there was no
specifics in terms of how you get at
that renewable agriculture funding
so I wondered whether the federal
efforts to help achieve more renewable
farming practices could help address
Trevor Hardy's question and the plight
of Many a New Hampshire grower who was
seeing costs Skyrocket in a time when
farms and Open Spaces are under
increasing economic pressure
it turns out farmers are quite concerned
with warming temperatures and seasonal
effects to farming so they are open to
the idea of using some of their land to
generate local clean power
but The Upfront costs in most cases are
prohibitive
so I called the New Hampshire USDA
conservationists that I met at that
Woodmont event to get more information
for the bill that was forming in my mind
and I received a call back from her
today on my way to Concord which was
really funny she had been out and didn't
know that I called so we had a nice long
chat and she is looking into
um just so you know by way of History I
I met with
um commissioner Jasper who's behind me
and going to testify as well
um and both he and the department of
energy had looked into the IRA funding
and they didn't really see any place
explicitly that they thought could be
used for a program of this type
so
um
you know it takes a lot of people to try
and figure out what's going on with some
of these really complex programs
um but when she called back and this has
been confirmed by Senator Shaheen's
office who called me back today uh
there's a program called the rural
energy for America program reap
and there's two billion dollars funded
uh through the IRA in that program that
is intended to assist with renewable
energy and Energy Efficiency projects
for Farms and so what they are telling
us is that
um in many cases the government is not
trying the federal government is not
trying to tell States what programs they
have to design they are saying build it
and we will come with the money so
they're basically saying if you if you
figure out how you need to spend the
money we can supply money we have
tranches of money
so you can see the Dilemma is you know
it's a cart before the horse thing
um
so I did get calls back from both of
those offices that I had been pending to
hear from before I spoke with
commissioner Jasper
um and uh to his credit he did say if
you can figure out where the money's
coming from then we'll go forward with
it
um so
um so basically the bill was uh as
submitted had some weaknesses which uh
commissioner Jasper brought to my
attention turn around for a report was
too aggressive I was looking at this
year he's like we can't do that
um and there were several other
um
pieces that came back uh from the in the
time in the turnaround that I had to get
the bill uh signed off
um I I didn't have time to make it
perfect but what I wanted to do since I
had more information is I wanted to send
around copies of edits uh for your
consideration now that the bill is in
your hands they're in red because for
some reason my Acrobat Reader wouldn't
let me do strikethroughs like they do in
OLS so I made the changes and I I have
copies here
um
so what I would ask is that we
understand that although it may not be
clear to us
um which monies can help our Farmers to
lower their costs and to make
investments that will keep energy
dollars in New Hampshire and stabilize
our food supply and those businesses and
those lands which I think are all
desirable things for us as a state to be
considering
um what I'm asking for in the bill is a
task force that will further investigate
this issue and so I never expected to
have all the answers at the time of the
hearing and I clearly do not
um but with the edits that I'm giving
you I think it is something that that
could move forward and I did send all
those edits out electronically to all
the co-sponsors on the bill so with that
if anyone has any questions
um I'll try to answer them
thank you representative McGee now
excuse me I have this paper that was
sent around and I there isn't enough for
everybody apparently I'm a small
operation yeah I I oh okay
um and this is where you had some
changes made in red yeah so you're not
offering an amendment it's just
changes I didn't have I didn't have time
and I thought that if the since it's the
committee's bill now if you needed an
amendment you could use that as your
launch pad yeah
I see okay thank you
uh do we have any questions for
representative McGee
um representative NAB
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question do you know
you know production act funds because I
know Arbor funds have sort of a timeline
I don't know on the state level I do
yeah it was a large uh Bill and
commissioner Jasper and I discussed that
they they don't run out until they don't
they're not intended to stop with
funding until 2031. so it's a 10-year
investment where people have the
opportunity to figure out programs and
get the money out where it needs to go
yeah
representative Murray thank you madam
chair for taking my question thank you
representative so
a follow-up on that
on that no deadline to apply for the
reef funding or are you aware because
sometimes those windows open and it will
say apply by
right and I think part of the language
in the bill asks that the task force
figure out what those deadlines and
Milestones are because at this point we
don't have a window into which bucket
would be coming out of so I don't think
we know those details and it's a large
it's a large bill you know so there
there's a a guideline
um document but again there's a lot of
details beyond that
um I I just thought I could put together
some something to say this is what
this is what we would like to achieve
and let's make sure that we look into it
to see that we get whatever monies are
coming to us to help our Growers with um
transitioning their businesses so that
they're more stable
representative thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question sure
um and looking at this task force it's
all positives but I would like to
there's nowhere nowhere in this task
force where it discusses the negative
effects of having solar the toxicity of
the solar panels and what that will do
to the soil and the Farmland surrounding
it could you speak to that please sure
um I I'm not a solar expert I know
um that solar panels won't be leaching
into the ground unless they're you know
broken or left in a pile somewhere so
generally if someone has tracking arrays
or array you know solar panels on
buildings they're not at any risk for
contaminating the environment there is a
bill
um that was up for consideration last
session and is under consideration again
this time around for greater producer
responsibility which means that at the
point of someone creating
um
creating a merchandise that has a
potential Downstream to be affecting the
environment that they would then have to
build in either planning around that or
costs around what you would be able to
do with that at the at the end of the
life cycle but um I don't think that's
what we're looking to do here in terms
of the
you know I I think allowing people to
augment or offset costs
um with locally generated energy is
I don't see downsides to that I think
there are there are definitely
um other considerations that the
individual businesses would have to make
but
um
but I think the benefits significantly
outweigh any down any downside that can
be managed a representative company you
have a follow-up I do Madam chair thank
you
um when I look at things regarding
Agriculture and farming and just the
environment in general I I take a longer
approach because our Farmland is soils
are depleted we're trying to rebuild
them up and at some point these solar
panels or solar Farms or whatever they
are are going to be dumped into our
environment which will have a negative
effect on groundwater and the land
surrounding them and I think it's
important to look at that effect on
Farmland itself as part of a task force
because we need to look at the negatives
not just the positives
I would you agree
um thank you for the point
uh
uh yeah I had a couple of thoughts when
you when you started speaking
I I go back to my constituent who is a
Seventh Generation farmer in Hollis he
gave us a specific scenario and he said
um we have put all this land at Woodmont
into agricultural use we are seeing more
droughts and less ability to depend on
the rain to keep the crops going so his
suggestion was if we could put some
solar panels in at the top of a hill
over a water body that we could then
create a hydro we could you know we
could bring the water when we needed it
to the lands
there are many opportunities that we
have that I am not an expert on and none
of us likely are experts on what I'm
trying to do is open up the opportunity
for people who have projects that make
sense to be able to
you know leverage these federal dollars
in order to support
converting their operations
as far as Downstream panel uh
disposal that does come up a bit I'm on
science technology and energy you know
we have conversations about that it's a
20 to 30 year away problem and that
doesn't mean we don't have to think
about it but we have more immediate
problems that we're trying to solve by
these Investments today and that's
that's what I'm trying to address so I
think that a task force that has once
they formulate and they have those
concerns I think they would very much be
able to address them but
um it was beyond the scope of what I was
trying to initiate with the bill
thank you
thank you representative Bixby you had a
question yeah so um I actually have a
couple questions but I'm going to start
with one uh so would the task force be
actively helping farmers get the money
or would they be figuring out what we
need to do next to help them get the
money
I think it would be up to the task force
how they would most effectively assist
Farmers I I wasn't trying to prescribe
the solutions I was trying to say
there's something we can put together
here and I would like to see a task
force of people who know more than I do
about agriculture figure out what
Solutions are appropriate but it's
certainly
the farmers that I know my community is
about 40 agricultural I know quite a few
farmers and they don't look up from
farming you know they're not going to go
out and seek things very often
um so
I would hope that if we did come up with
a program that there would be some way
that the task force would figure out to
reach out into the agricultural
Community through our our commissioner
and through the communicator and other
vehicles that we have that farmers do
pay attention to
Sure representative Bixby yes so
um another
um
thought I had was I'm wondering if this
is strictly for solar or if uh there so
I know that a lot of a lot of the farms
in the state are in areas served by the
New Hampshire Electric Cooperative and
they're starting a uh program which
allows uh the customers to that have
backup batteries to uh get the best time
of time of day time of use so it's um I
think it's called transactive Yes Energy
um so swarms my heart so
um I'm wondering if uh helping farmers
get up for doing a setup for doing
transactive energy would also be part of
this task force or would that have to be
something different
well it's it's a really good question
um it is again beyond the scope maybe a
little more ambitious than what I was
trying to Define in this bill
um the benefit of transactive energy is
if we have batteries or vehicles that
can go both ways through a smart meter
then you can actually put energy back
where it's when it's needed so
uh that is uh dependent upon our
infrastructure so we have a ways to go
before that's something that can be done
but if there was forethought into the
installations that are being placed
around the state
on rural land then certainly we could we
could make those installations be more
supportive of our future infrastructure
for sure
I I
um the other representative Bixby so a
very small question so I'm much just
wondering about the term sunlit is there
is that anything specific or is that
just I'm just goofy
okay I wanted to give it a name so it
had uh you know a way to plant in your
brain representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
question thank you representative
I have uh one question regarding the
composition of the task force members
looks like there are seven members named
uh currently and I was just curious I
may have missed it but um would you be
open to including Farmers specifically
on the task force
uh there is a member of the Agricultural
Community listed I believe oh I see that
I apologize thank you um
and yes I had actually two and also two
from the solar industry I mean I was
trying to figure out who what kind of
expertise was needed on the makeup of
the committee
um but I was cautioned that you know
getting committee members to attend and
attend on a regular basis is hard so I I
lowered the number required and I and I
would think like many other
um committees or task forces that we put
together in the state of New Hampshire
if we need additional stakeholders that
have special expertise then they would
just be asked to join for whatever was
needed and follow up if I may yes you
may thank you madam chair and then
additionally additionally with
once the task force would be formed with
whatever composition you're you're
outlining here would you be open to that
being submitted to the
Department of markets Agriculture and
Foods the findings of that report it
looks like it's currently only going to
stne and the Senate energy and natural
resources
well the chair of the committee was
intended to be the chair of the
Commissioner of Agriculture and or
designee so it would be coming from the
agricultural Department as the the
department that would be spearheading
the research so the reports coming back
to the two committees in the House and
Senate that have oversight for
the
um okay the qualities that are in the
bill is is just really a way of us
understanding where did it land what did
you come up with is it going forward is
there anything else that's needed so
um I I did also include business and
economic development I believe
um we always try to get someone from
business and economic development to be
on the stakeholder
um group so I did try to
figure out who should be on the team but
um as I said it doesn't preclude any
other people that the commissioner or
others think should be involved from
being added
in an ad hoc way thank you
thank you presenting Bixby
uh another question about uh the
participants
um I'm wondering about uh number uh
letter e an expert on procurring federal
funding from for state agencies
appointed by the uh Commissioner of
Department of Agriculture markets of
foods and I'm wondering if the
department actually has such a person
um I have since found out that that
there may not exist a person of that ilk
um there are people who certainly know
more about what's going on with the
federal funding than we do which is why
I put USDA in there and I had not heard
back from them at that time and I was
assuming that they would be the correct
department and now I'm hearing uh that
the tranche of money may not actually be
under them but under this other rural
program that I gave you the name of the
reap program so
um there's more investigation to do on
it and I uh we do have a New Hampshire
USDA office
whether they have a resource that they
could commit to this I don't know I did
have feedback from one other person that
I asked to co-sponsor the bill saying
well we don't have any control over the
U.S folks and they're not you know so we
can't make them be part of this
committee but what I was thinking was
that what might be missing on the
committee is someone who actually
understood how to interact with the
the federal pieces of the law to figure
it out so that's why I wanted to try and
add that
okay
representative Creighton
thank you for your testimony and and
your really thinking about how to take
advantage of these opportunities
going back to paragraph 200 the
membership
um I noticed you I don't see a member of
the house or Senate on there is that uh
was the reasoning behind that there
isn't any I I honestly didn't even think
of it
um and I know that when we have
commissions we generally have membership
from both both sides of the house we
dictate that and I would be amenable to
you adding that um the makeup of the
committee I was just trying to get to
the point where I had a starter bill
that had what to me made sense but I I'm
not an expert so I would defer to you if
you think that somebody else should be
added that would be great thank you
ma'am
any other questions for
representative Bixby thank you because
it's a small question also so
um this bill will obviously need some
amending and uh I'm wondering
um
uh I'm just thinking about the timeline
for that we have do you know if this is
an early bill or a regular Bill and uh
would you be will if we set a
subcommittee on working on this would be
you would be willing to help out getting
us the information we need
I think a subcommittee is a great idea
and early Bill late bill it's not nearly
bill it doesn't have an FN or anything
it's not going to a second committee
that I'm aware of okay thank you you're
welcome
anyone else with a question I I have a
question too I did get an email from
uh Carol Foss
uh who is asking if it would be amenable
to have a representative
of the natural resources conservation
service be added to this list of people
that makes a lot of sense okay
thank you thank you any other questions
from anyone thank you for your testimony
today thank you call up um Griffin
robarge from New Hampshire energy
Department
who submitted a pink card
that's a mighty big book
yeah
sorry a lot of energy bills this year
um thank you uh chairwoman
um uh Griffin Roberts from the New
Hampshire Department of energy I am the
state energy program planner with the
department and regularly testify usually
before the house st e committee on
energy related bills the department is
neutral on House Bill 369 but just
wanted to share some observations to
start I do I did appreciate the
opportunity to speak with representative
McGee about this bill when it was in the
LSR drafting stage just to understand
the reasoning behind the bill as well as
the Genesis of it the
to back up a little bit in my role at
the New Hampshire Department of energy
I'm responsible for
monitoring various Federal funding
opportunities coming down through the
infrastructure investment and jobs act
which passed a couple years back as I
shouldn't say a couple years back
um but and then also the inflation
reduction act which was signed into law
in August of last year
um
regarding this bill is it focuses on
federal funding coming out of the
inflation reduction act based on at
least my review of various funding
opportunities coming down through that
bill there is no agriculturally focused
funding Federal funding opportunity that
states would then apply to and then
sub-grant out to eligible uh recipients
a lot as representative McGee mentioned
a lot of that money is going into
existing uh agricultural based programs
so for example two billion dollars more
into the rural energy for America
program and that program runs regularly
through the U.S department of
Agriculture offering a combination of
loans and grants to rural small
businesses agricultural producers for
Energy Efficiency improvements renewable
energy those types of projects
um
so I just at least wanted to highlight
that and that if this bill is to go
forward a big question mark at least in
my eyes would be what federal funding
opportunity would we be
targeting I guess with this task force
um moving on down at least until the
other stuff is um establish a criteria
an application process line 26.
um
based on at least the prime sponsors
indication is that the bill would
actively promote funding opportunities
to
um to agricultural interests and
producers this language here at least in
the Department's view in
um online 26 on page one kind of
indicates that the task force might be
creating uh its own program Criterion
application process I would just caution
against that just because with federal
dollars comes Federal strengths there
are process there are processes
expectations regulations compliance
standards that follow federal dollars if
the state were to go another way and
outline its own application process over
a federal process
you'd get you I think you could
understand that there might be a
compliance mix up there
um in terms of little c
um and using federal funds to provide
tax credits if there were a federal
funding opportunity to Avail ourselves
of again uh as I mentioned before you'd
want to know a little bit more about
what the federal strings are for that is
when if the state were to apply for
federal funds if they did exist and we
could use them are we able to then
create some type of tax credit system
with those dollars if you can't you
can't again it's it's it is a big
question mark there I know that there
are a number of tax incentives under the
IRA federal tax incentives uh the
department of energy is certainly not
any type of tax professional if Farmers
or agricultural producers are interested
in a tax credits they should certainly
talk with any tax consultant or tax
professional for sure and then finally
on page two uh uh paragraph D about
making a recommendation about an
agricultural net metering credit I just
wanted to mention that this uh that net
metering obviously as legislators might
know is a recurring issue
um every year and pending legislation
there is an ongoing docket currently at
the Public Utilities Commission to
determine uh potential changes to the
net metering tariff
um and then finally
um the only other thing I would just
note is that the inflation reduction Act
was signed in into law in August of last
year
Federal guidance for various funding out
of that bill is slow and continuing to
evolve so if there were a federal
funding opportunity again we'd like to
know a little bit more in terms of the
details as to what comes with that those
dollars the other resource I would
direct the committee to is that the
White House put out as it did with the
infrastructure Bill an IRA guide book
and basically that book for about 100
150 Pages outlines all the various tax
credits tax incentives Federal funding
programs coming down through the uh
inflation reduction act I can certainly
share that with the committee but each
page kind of outlines just a one page of
what the different programs are and just
by looking through a lot of the
Agricultural related ones a lot of the
eligible eligibility for those programs
is just open to agricultural producers
themselves again to reiterate as I said
it's not necessarily something where you
put the state in the position to apply
and then sub Grant out these dollars
it's largely between the federal
government and the agricultural
producers themselves and with that more
than happy to take any questions I
apologize for going on
thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair I know with other
grant opportunities sometimes the U.S
Department of Treasury offers guidance
and I was curious to know whether or not
that is the case with some of the things
that you're currently mentioning sure so
in term thank you for the question
um in terms of the agriculture related
incentives it depends on the on the
federal agency that rolls through so for
example a lot of the you know energy
related stuff dealing with Energy
Efficiency renewable energy might throw
roll through the U.S department of
energy a lot of these agricultural
things might roll through say the U.S
department of interior or the U.S
department of Agriculture so it kind of
depends as to which federal agency gets
the jurisdiction thank you okay
representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking my question
um so you you mentioned that many of the
subsidies seem that available for
agriculture seem to be direct from the
feds to the farmers and I'm wondering
how a small New Hampshire farmer figures
out how to negotiate that process when
they are spending from like 5 a.m to
8 P.M in the fields I I get that thank
you for the question representative
um
I I I guess my comments just to focus
were just on the bill is introduced I
haven't seen a potential language
changes that I think the prime sponsor
shared a few moments earlier
um but obviously you know the U.S
department of Agriculture does have a
New Hampshire State office they
regularly try to work and uh they
regularly work with agricultural
producers interested stakeholders kind
of advertise these opportunities a lot
of information on the run on the rural
energy for America or reap program is
available online get an idea of what the
eligibility standards are and everything
like that personally though I do
understand that Federal compliances can
certainly be a bit of a headache if
you're dealing with Davis bacon buy
America requirements NEPA requirements
um that is that is burdensome but the
U.S department of Agriculture I believe
does have resources to try to help
farmers understand that
and certainly the reap program has been
something that's been ongoing
um and has obviously had success here in
New Hampshire and Vermont
thank you and I have a question do you
believe that it makes any sense to tie
this type of
uh commission or task force or program
to any one piece of federal legislation
like the inflation reduction act I mean
as you were saying that there are so
many different programs available
maybe we need you know the task force
just to be sort of the
data point of of many different programs
that are available for our farmers and
rural community nope and that's
understand and thank you for the
question
um at least in my role at the department
is I'm only speaking to U.S department
of energy related funding programs is uh
we've tried to go through the
infrastructure bill and the IRA and
create web pages on our website to kind
of advertise certain select funding
opportunities
respectfully the department does not
have the bandwidth to advertise every
single one and not every single one
might not be at may not be applicable to
constituencies in New Hampshire uh but
that's at least what you know uh the the
New Hampshire Department of energy is
doing on U.S department of energy
related funding initiatives
um whether or not a state task force
might help better bridge that Gap to
advertise these opportunities you know
that's worthy of consideration it's just
I think the main point I wanted to make
in our in the bill today was when it
mentions funding from the IRA it's at in
our first glance we're unclear as to
what specific funding opportunities the
task force would be
looking at and potentially advertising
out okay thank you very much for that
um any other questions from the
committee
no seeing none
I thank you for your taking money today
and I call uh commissioner Jasper to
come and speak about HB 369
welcome back
thank you it seems like like days
um thank you for the opportunity to test
uh testify did have a very good
conversation uh last week with the
sponsor and I applaud her efforts on
behalf of New Hampshire uh farmers and I
appreciate
her uh attempt to be Innovative I do
have concerns
um
and I appreciate the testimony of the
Department of energy because
um the conclusions they have come to are
the same that I have come to I did spend
considerable amount of time
going through the bill
so 295 page Bill and there's
specifically somewhere in the vicinity
of 25 30 pages that um
do relate to Farms but throughout the
bill
it primarily about tax credits loans
that are partially
forgivable and um
in Grants to energy producers
um
I'm not sure that it with our the scale
of things when you look at the United
States
that there's much opportunity for New
Hampshire Farms to be seen as energy
producers when there is a limited amount
of money here that doesn't mean we
shouldn't look at it
but my main concern is really
that this is something that is way out
of the Wheelhouse of the traditional
function of the New Hampshire Department
of Agriculture as you learned last week
we're already up to our eyeballs
um
I really as much as I applaud the
efforts here I don't see how I have the
time to Be an Effective leader of this
this group because I do have
um many many legislative uh response
responsibilities that the legislature
has put upon us our traditional role
when it comes to these type of federal
programs is managing grants
that grants come to us in blocks and
then we put those out I'm very hesitant
to say that I would be amenable to
saying that we would now be an agency
that goes out there and looks for grants
that farmers could apply for on their
own and now we would direct direct that
to them that's more an education process
my thought is because this is a
nationwide process this is something
that American Farm Bureau should be
doing if there is an opportunity here
this is something that the Farm Bureau
should be putting together teaching
people how to do this maybe on a
national level uh Cooperative Extension
but I'm not sure this is something they
would normally get into
either but yeah the the bottom line is
um that I don't I don't see that I have
any of the expertise within my office
to be helpful on this that putting the
commissioner in charge of this is
something that you know I'm not going to
to sign sign on for of course the
legislature can direct me to
stand on my head and spit wooden nickels
if they'd like me to but I don't think
that'll go over that'll work very well
either and I I'm not trying to be snarky
it's just there are only so many hours
in the day there's only so much
um expertise that we have and this is
not one of one of those areas and um you
know I did make a sincere attempt to see
what are the opportunities for
um for us to help
farmers and it's way out of what
normally happens I think that the trade
organizations need to be the ones really
looking out how do you apply for these
things because where does it stop now
we become a tax
advice agency where we're going to give
advice to everybody on well here's an
opportunity for you individually I am
very very happy
to manage grants and to do that and as
you heard last week I think this year
you know we we are managing something
like four and a half million dollars
which you know is a couple million
dollars less than our entire budget so I
think we did do a pretty good job but
um I'll I'll stop now uh
thank you Mr commissioner and I don't
know when we'll schedule that bill uh
having to do with you standing on your
head
um
any members of the committee have a
question for commissioner Jasper
thank you very much for your
your testimony
I call now Ben Ming
from Hollis
welcome Mr Ming thank you
Madam chair
Madam chair Aaron Vice chair Creighton
and members of the environment and
agricultural committee my name is Ben
Ming I'm a state representative from
Hollis and I thank you for your time in
listening to my support for HB 369 a
bill with bipartisan sponsorship that
seeks to establish a farm energy funding
task force
I'm not a farmer I don't and I don't
work in the agricultural industry
but agriculture is important to my
district so I will be speaking about
what it means to my community
during the late summer and fall people
descend on Hollis and towns like it to
pick apples load up on corn and select
the perfect pumpkin
with the scenic fields and beautiful
foliage it is truly the best time of
year and we owe much of it to the
multi-generational farming families that
not only keep these Traditions alive
but if shepherded the lands over the
decades on behalf of a community that
Above All Else values rural character
over this past summer I was able to
attend a legislative tour of Woodmont
orchards in Hollis also in attendance
was Kat McGee the prime sponsor of this
bill
we are treated to an explanation of how
efficient farming
was being used in our hometown and the
state of agriculture in Hollis
Hillsborough County and across New
Hampshire
a multitude of ways to potentially help
New Hampshire agriculture were discussed
at varying points of the presentation
and in one-on-one conversations with
farmers
this included supporting their labor
force fixing a slow to non-existent
educational pipeline
and making Investments towards efficient
farming
efficiency and more specifically no-till
farming were the main focus of the day
it allows cover crop to be flattened
seeds to be planted and a few other
things again I'm not a farmer
and all done in a single pass
this saves on the use of multiple
machines Fuel and labor
it's better for the land for the land
and if there was a single point that was
made about this level of efficient
farming
it was that it required planning
patients and a conscious and intentional
investment at both the federal and state
level to make it possible
I also learned of the high energy costs
in farming and how much of it could be
offset by solar energy
High electric bills are not just a
problem for the average citizen this is
why I'm here before you today
the point of House Bill 369 is
exploratory
by creating the sublet Farm energy
relief task force we are acknowledging
one of the many challenges that New
Hampshire farmers face
they've made the effort to leverage
federal funds earmarked for more
efficient farming
and I believe that if there's any
possibility that the inflation reduction
Act of 2022
holds funds that could be used in
advance use to advance their farming we
owe them to make the effort to look for
it
thank you and I'll take any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions from the committee
representative Murray
thank you madam chair thank you
representative
available to other folks outside of
traditional farming that might be other
types of agricultural producers
um thank you for your question
um I took a brief look at the handbook
for the IRA and um I know one thing that
stuck out to me was funding for
um conservation plans
uh that stuck out to me and it could be
done through
um your local select board I believe but
that was
just a brief look through of the
handbook so um I believe so but I'd have
to do a little more research
thank you
thank you representative burlard
thank you madam chair uh representative
Ming has there been any contact with uh
U.S congressman uh Chris Pappas or say
Annie Custer
um thank you on this issue oh yeah sure
uh thank you for your question
um there hasn't
um as a co-sponsor I've been and a first
time rep I've been learning the ropes so
um all all that information was kind of
put on
um representative McGee um so I think
that question is probably best suited to
to ask her
I only ask because I'm sure they're the
ones that voted for the inflation
reduction act so
it could be helpful to contact them yes
thank you thank you
any other questions for Mr Ming
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony today
um I do not have any other pink cards
for Testimony anybody else would like to
submit testimony I sit up nope okay
representative Bixby
activities that we have representative
notice we have a representative from the
Farm Bureau New Hampshire Farm Bureau
here and I was wondering if uh he would
be willing to
um make any comment on the suggestion
that the Farm Bureau might be a better
place for helping Channel These funds
sorry to put you on the spot Rob please
join us Mr Johnson
Rob Johnson policy director of the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau Federation and
represent Bixby and NCT a question it's
it's something we did sign in and
support
we're well aware of the the resource
challenges the Department of Agriculture
as far as Farm Bureau doing something
like this in New Hampshire uh I mean
we're challenged as well it would have
to be you know I have to go back to my
board and would have to talk about it
and see this you know what kind of a
priority it is we a few years back see a
few years back 10 12 years ago we did
have a specific energy committee that
did meet for a while I think like with a
lot of things once the pandemic hit a
lot of things fell by the wayside and
that was one of them maybe it's time we
need to reinvigorate that and look at
something like this
thank you representative Murray and
would you mind also before before you
leave to fill out a pink card so that we
have it for the record will do go ahead
thank you madam chair
thank you Mr Johnson for taking my
question one of the questions that I did
have was with regard to to
folks who do help assist Farmers with
grants what what type of experience do
you have at the Farm Bureau with
connecting them to resources for that
need for grant writing
not themselves but for resources to seek
those grants
yeah
we'd be pointing them in another
direction we don't have anybody on staff
but would be looking at corporate
extension if possible usually usually if
there's a grant that's usually a certain
uh entity that that we're you know
depending on the entity depending on the
grant itself where we point them rural
development USC rule development maybe
another
and I should add too is the this the uh
sponsor mentioned that she had this idea
came out of Hollis and with in
particular with uh Trevor high of
Brookdale Fruit Farm uh Trevor is one of
my bosses he sits on a board of
directors just so you're aware
okay thank you any other questions for
Mr Johnson
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
I guess that uh wraps it up for uh
testimony on HB 369 according to the
blue sheet we've got three people in
favor of this legislation
online we had five people in support and
two people opposing
I'm going to close the hearing on HB 369
and my apologies to those folks waiting
for hb252 which we were supposed to
start at 1 30.
and
um we give a moment for our clerk to
get settled
and I will open up the hearing for hb252
which is exempting agricultural
operations from certain Municipal noise
ordinance
and we have today
um introducing this bill
our very own
Barbara comptwa representative kantois
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
uh the reason this bill has come about
is over the summer it was brought to my
attention and also in my own town that
uh they're trying to put in noise
ordinances that would have a negative
impact uh to Farms
um which would again go to Food security
and uh people processing
um so what this seeks to do is to exempt
farming activities from any municipal or
local noise ordinance
the actual chapter 21 34A lies out
specifically what activities those are
um it was brought to my attention that a
amendment should come forth which I am
willing to do dealing with agritourism
should be exempt from this particular
um
bill regarding noise ordinances
over the summer I got a call from
somebody in a town in
Southern New Hampshire
where the person the owner of the farm
was spraying their apple orchard
and if anyone understands farming in
when spraying needs to be done it has to
be done before the bees are out so very
early in the morning
or
at night when everything is basically
shut down
and the other thing you have to take
into consideration is Windrift
so there's a lot of components that go
into taking care of farms that people
don't realize it's very scientific you
have to monitor the weather you have to
make sure it's not going to rain the
next day you have to make sure it's not
windy so that things don't spread and at
this particular time it was nine o'clock
in the evening when this Farm decided
that this was the best time to do this
so that there would be no Wind Drift or
any application spreading to the
properties next door
the neighbors complained the town had a
noise ordinance
no noise after a certain time
and so it ensued that town actually went
ahead and put into a rule uh that that
farm could actually do that but as we
are increasing our populations and more
people are moving into our rural areas
we are finding that this is becoming
more and more of an issue
um
the
policy director was telling me of a
story up in Littleton the chicken
someone had a rooster
and they put in noise ordinance now the
roost had been there for quite some time
and they decided to go after this
particular person because the rooster
crowed at the wrong time of day
this particular person
insulated their
chicken house they put up room darkening
Shades and everything else that they
could possibly think of
and yet the rooster still crowed well
when the rooster wanted to Crow and
therefore was forced to get rid of that
these are some of the issues that we are
facing in the farming and agricultural
community
and it's becoming more and more
prevalent more and more municipalities
are putting in noise ordinances that
have a negative adverse effect which
will end up having an adverse effect on
our food supply here in New Hampshire
and as we all know or if we don't know
we can only feed six percent of our
population currently today with New
Hampshire Farms
I'd say that's pretty dismal so anything
we can do to protect them I think it is
in our best interest to do and I would
ask that you would seriously consider
this bill and I'm open for questions
thank you representative comp toy any
questions from the committee
representative Knapp
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I just wonder if you
already have an exemption for
agricultural businesses or farms in
terms of noise ordinances
um thank you for the question I am not
sure I do know that this particular
problem happened in Pelham New Hampshire
so they did put one in but they did call
myself they talked to the commissioner
and uh to the Farm Bureau so
um but even in my town they try to put a
noise ordinance in last year
um fortunately I come from agricultural
town we the farmers uh
took exception and then they said they
were going to put in a noise ordinance
study committee
um but it will have an adverse effect
um as Farmers we we understand that you
may have to start your tractor up at 1am
in the morning to pull out a calf or you
know there could be an emergency
or you might have to chop down a tree
that's on a uh you know one of your
fences and to be told that you could be
fined because of a noise ordinance is
really not the New Hampshire way
uh representative I have a question
um
in your
in your bill I guess it is on
line
seven
wait a minute it says new paragraph
powers of City councils bylaws and
ordinances
uh agricultural activities exempt amend
RSA 47
I think
it might be 47 colon 17.
I don't know that
um thank you madam chair it says by
inserting amend RSA 47 by inserting
after paragraph 19 the following new
paragraph So you're not taking something
out you're putting in the new paragraph
Yes but
um the
is just uh powers of city councils and
it lists 47 colon 1 through 47 colon 28.
so I don't know
where the
X1 X well 19 Roman numeral goes unless
it's in 47 colon 17
. thank you I do not have that Iris
a in front of me I apologize uh we'll
have to check the numbers then to make
sure that
we're looking at the right section of
this RSA correct because I have RSA 3139
printed out in RSA uh you know the
chapter 2134a okay would you double
check that then I will absolutely check
that for you thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Bixby oh and I'll get to
you
so
um one thing that I I
uh in terms of which body has control
over uh things like noise and
municipalities is the do
um
do municipalities have home rules so
they can make up the rules on their own
or does that rule need to be given does
that power need to be given to them by
the state
thank you for the question
representative Bixby it is my
understanding that if I'm looking
correctly under the powers and duties of
towns powers to make bylaws I believe
that they can
it says in here let me just look real
quickly but I believe they are charged
with where they can put in ordinances
regarding noise
okay so so in other words that's
something that the state has delegated
to them as as a power I believe that is
correct if I go back through here and
read it thank you
representative Morse
thank you and thank you for taking my
question so um my question was very
similar to Peter's but I'm also
wondering if there's anything that you
want to put in here about like the size
of the farmer agriculture or is are we
talking about the person who has three
chickens and a rooster do they qualify
as a farm and you know are we looking
into
um like the size of the town or how
rural they are compared to how Urban
they are or will there be anything in
that regard
thank you for the question
representative Morse
um
according to this and I'll just read
this the word Farm means any land
Building or structures on on or which in
which Agriculture and farming are
operations or activities are carried out
or conducted and shall include the
residences of residents of owners
occupants or employees located on such
land
that doesn't really give you a really
good idea of what farming is
but I don't believe that a backyard
homeowner is considered a farm I think
that there is a clear distinction
um or somewhat but you have to
understand there are people that are
starting out small as you know you could
have a farm on a quarter acre and do
quite a lot of in Revenue
um so if we look at size as a definition
I think it will be detrimental to the
agricultural community
foreign
sorry representative Murray
my apologies no it's okay
uh thank you representative Murray for
the question
um
you know I would actually have to look
up the definition of farm in statute
um in order to do that and I don't have
that in front of me and I do apologize
for that
um but it says here
um it's husbandry of poultry or game
birds husbandry of bees or production of
honey
the production of greenhouse crops our
practice or activity on the farm
accident okay
um preparation
you know for Market
so there's a lot of components to
farming so you know you might be
homesteading but you also might be a
small farm at the same time because
maybe you're going to the farmers
markets to sell you Wares in hopes that
you grow
I mean
we need everyone to be participating in
our local food economy so that we can be
sustainable in the state
representative NAB
um I apologize for not knowing this
because it might have been in the
farming definition but does timber
harvesting fall into this category and
so would logging operations also be
included in these in this restriction
thank you representative NAB for that
question and yes it does
any other questions
thank you representative thank you madam
chair
I'd like to call on Nat's Grace
from New Hampshire Municipal Association
good afternoon and welcome to
environment agriculture thank you madam
chair I'm not usually in this committee
um so I'll just introduce myself briefly
I'm Nate Graves with the municipal
Association we're voluntary membership
organization of cities and towns
throughout New Hampshire we currently
are comprised of all 234 cities and
towns we provide legal advice uh
training and of course come here and
Advocate and we do oppose legislation
that would directly
take away from existing local
authorities so we are opposing this
legislation I apologize I haven't had a
chance to speak with the prime sponsor
about this bill in particular
um a number of you had some specific
questions we'll start with you madam
chair uh you are correct that it is
47.17 that you'd like to um you'd like
to add in that colon 17.
um
as far as I understand for the
definition of farm under 2134 for a and
I don't normally practice in this area
of law so I I'm not 100 certain but it
is a very broad definition
I don't believe it's limited in terms of
in terms of
how much actual acreage is in production
representative Bixby asked a question
about whether municipalities already are
charged with um regulating noise and
they they are towns are under
um 3139 and cities under 47-17
um
it
realistically putting in noise
ordinances is very complicated
um a number of noise ordinances have
been struck down over the years because
they haven't been specific enough if we
were contacted to provide advice to
municipalities about them we would
suggest that they do something involving
decibels and decibel levels and also
look at the type of activity that's
going on in their communities and
appropriately gauge that activity you
know if you have whether it's
agriculture activity or something you
know a cement plant or something and
that's a major employer in your town
obviously it's not very wise to pass an
ordinance that would effectively Outlaw
or make their business difficult
um so while there is no
currently existing uh requirement that
um they take that into consideration and
certainly Our advice that you look at
what your town does and appropriately uh
gauge your uh gauge your ordinance and
of course given that it is something
adopted at town meeting for towns it's
something that's open for debate and
hopefully uh there's a robust
conversation about that
um
and that's that's really what I I wanted
to offer certainly I'm happy
um to
make the suggestion that if if the
committee believes that it's the case
that this is a
um
a training a training or education issue
we do provide uh training and education
to our members we did some around 80
events with 40 staff members last year
certainly I'm happy to put this on the
docket
um and do some specific reach out as
well I'm happy to take any questions the
committee may have thank you
representative Bixby
for taking my question so um
if we were to go ahead with this bill uh
would it make it more palatable to your
organization if we were to exclude uh
the activities related to agrotourism
so I'd have to look up the definition of
agriculture agritourism again
um I do know that
under the land use statutes agritourism
is protected uh protected use much like
agricultural use so for example if I
want to put a
Farm Stand in my front yard selling
vegetables that I grow there I'm allowed
to do that the municipality can't stop
me
um
I guess the
realistically what our position is is
that we have to protect our our charges
to protect um existing local authorities
so I I don't think there's a lot of room
for compromise here thank you
any other questions from the committee
thank you thank you
I'd like to call up now um Bob Johnson
from New Hampshire Farm Bureau
thank you
appreciate it
thank you madam chair members of the
committee again for the record Rob
Johnson representing the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau as the federation's policy
director and this is my well second time
now up to speak I haven't planned on
speaking before let me take a minute or
so tell you a little bit about Farm
Bureau where a non-profit Federation of
New Hampshire's 10 County Farm Bureau
organizations those organizations
consist of a total of about uh 3 000
members of those members or mostly
family members or 1800 1900 our farmer
members remaining are supporting members
and businesses and we are what we call a
a Grassroots organization where our
policy is developed from our members up
we're a general Farm organization where
we represent all types of Agriculture
and
um
just a little background on the history
been in existence just over a hundred
years and we started back at the the
early 1900s when the federal government
uh said to uh the the counties that if
if you want a County Extension agent an
AG agent what are now called
agricultural Educators if you want one
of a nag agent in your county you need
to show proof by having a a farm
organization established and that's how
the Farm Bureau started we and we
maintain our close relationship with
Cooperative Extension to this day
um as far as uh 252 goes we we are we
are supportive uh we we would like to
see uh some Protections in statute
where I hear the issue most often in
representative quantois alluded to it
regarding roosters uh is a big one and
then tractors and then uh farm equipment
is another one and she also alluded to
with sprayers is is is an area and again
as you all think are aware agriculture
is is a weather dependent and that's
whether that's rain whether that's wind
whether that's heat cold that type of
thing and when you're talking about
spraying you you need to spray when
there is no wind and that requires the
most most commonly the the wind is down
early in the day or late in the evening
and so in in where the issues come about
is where there's people move in from
outside may not be familiar with
agriculture or the area and then as a
and then you get into it with us there's
complaints and it's it can be you're
going to say it doesn't happen a whole
lot but it can be a real error to a
farmer trying to deal with this issue
because when it comes to noise it I I
I'd say it's quite subjective what can
be noisy to one person is not to another
and it's it's kind of like with odors as
well it's a it's a real Challenge on
dealing with it I passed out the the
state definition of agriculture I would
say 21 colon 34-a and in a kind of in
looking at moving this forward which we
would like to see that that as as the
municipal Association pointed out 2134a
is very Broad in that in many ways it's
a good thing but when you're trying to
insert it into this legislation it's
probably it's probably it's too broad we
recognize that agritourism is asked
earlier is included and you'll see that
I highlighted it the irsa has section
two it's the words Agriculture and
farming mean all operations or
activities they'll Farm in including in
that section A that really gets into
what most people consider the heart and
soul of Agriculture the cropping of land
in the in the care and raising of
livestock and then when you get into B
which is you turn the page that's where
you get into the incidental practices
and that's where agriters agritourism is
included so again if we we would like to
see the the bill move forward but I I
think you that does need to be put some
sideboards on that and and that it'd be
really uh
you come up with something that where
there's some limitations whether it be
you know in in rural zones could be uh
an area but
um
and I I Madam I guess I'll leave my
testimony uh that thank you thank you
very much questions representative Knapp
thank you very much Madam chair I just
um so the the language of the log stops
farming and agriculture agricultural
operations
um but in this statute I would I'm
concerned and I wonder if you are the
sponsor
um thinks that farm would be included
because then you do get into the
residence of the farmer and is there the
possibility of someone working on their
own house and that being included within
this
this permit or this the the way the bill
is drafted it it's
2134a encompassing Farm Agriculture and
farming and that's why we're that's why
we're saying it it does make it very
Broad and maybe if you if it were
limited to the you know look in that
sections uh 2A and B you're correct as
written it does include Farm which does
include uh the the residents of the
farmer and employee uh housing as well
thank you all right can I ask a
follow-up should the other place that I
would ask about or that gives me pause
is the writing instruction of equines
because I think that also might be
outside of what people think of as
farming if you are teaching horse
lessons
um and not so it you know I just I guess
I would question how broad this whole
definition is which you you are speaking
to
um how broadly we would interpreted for
for a noise ordinance yeah I mean we
would include equine as agriculture yeah
in the in that statue clearly does
including a Writing Center
correct
so I have a question
um
in your experience
where you've heard that farmers or
members of the rural community
have had complaints against them for
whatever noises come from their
place
do you know what has happened is that
have they had to cease and desist were
they
threatened with lawsuits or
how how much of I mean I know that noise
has been a problem for people who are
not familiar with it and move into an
area and then they say oh my God you
know the Sawmill is making all this
noise
um how how much of a problem is it
really and what what kinds of
um
penalties are people being threatened
with
well it runs the gamut well kind of
getting to the earlier question about
size it the way the statute reads
agriculture is agriculture is no size
it's it's very small very large So you
you're getting into that so and it's
um
I'm trying to think back at it like
roosters is one example in in uh um the
sponsor mentioned it was most recent
incident that we dealt with was in
Franconia and in that case the
individual I mean she did she was did
everything you'd expect when usually
when I get members that call me with
this I say you know have you are you
trying to make accommodation you know
are you just you know basically you're
just ignoring it or are you trying to
deal with it well this individual like
she had insulated her poultry house she
had put uh
um shading over Windows uh she had even
as a device you can purchase and put on
a rooster that will muffle its sound she
had done all that and it still was not
in the satisfaction of her neighbor in
her case her neighbor happened to be the
Town Administrator from what I was told
so then there was a town ordinance was
developed and so that's a little unique
circumstance there
um and my understanding is the last I
spoke to this individual they that was
she was getting ready to go to court is
that she planning on doing even though
it was again we're not talking a
commercial operation this was her so I I
don't know if she went through with it
after looking at everything
um
we had an incident in Dairy years ago
where as a young lady raising chickens
and it was like a kick out of it because
she had a roosterone see any complaints
and and I guess the city council had
questioned her and this is a I say young
lady she was eight or eight or nine
years old and she wrote the cutest
letter you'd ever read to the city
council as to the need for a rooster in
her the continuing of her operation and
in that instance you know it was where
that you have to get rid of the rooster
in the end because I understood it
um
I mean that's something I guess I would
you know getting a more concrete
examples if if that were to help but
certainly it's an issue where I I think
a big part of it is in the end these
issues are resolved I think most often
before they go to court but it's the
it's just the stress in Asia dealing
with it for an extended period of time
in the in the in the the threat I think
all of us in agriculture when you have a
farm and all of a sudden you know the
the house is built over near the Back
Forty you start to wonder am I going to
be you know what issues are going to
arise because they they do and most
often I have found I farm myself and and
most of my neighbors love the farm and
they you know they want they're
interested and want to be told about it
and they want to feel a part of it and
it's great
um and I I'm fortunate to haven't had
those but I know we we mentioned in the
the previous hearing that the uh the uh
farmer from Brookdale fruit farm and
Hollis that requested the the uh
legislation
um if I remember correctly Brookdale
Fruit Farm has I believe this it's
of 500 Butters something like that some
crazy number so I mean it can be an
awful uh it could be an awful lot of uh
of people that that again just just may
not understand the real needs and I I
think part of this that we see it is
geez if we get a little bit of a handle
on this now
as opposed to another 50 years but who
knows what the state's going to look
like trying to deal with it because you
know I know in more urban States it's a
it's a much bigger issue obviously
thank you any other questions from Mr
Johnson
Mr representative Bixby
so I believe that um that we also have a
right to farm statute somewhere in our
in our rsas and does this play into this
issue at all
well a right to farm that that that
applies to operations that have been in
existence for one year
um
it it it it it does but again when
you're getting into noise it can be so
nebulous as to it again it's like odors
as well everybody has a different idea
of what is noisy and what's not what
smells what doesn't that type of thing
thank you yeah it's a good question I I
feel I I should have brought that with
even more prepared with that
any other questions representative
Murray
on the right to farm statutes how that
intersects to the committee
certainly it's it's
um
I want to say it's 435 I believe and I
everybody yeah
I should I certainly can't do that yeah
okay 435
I can actually yeah I can tell you in a
minute exactly the statute of it in my
with my things
you want to take a moment
I could certainly get it too
okay
all right then any other questions I
don't see any other pink cards for this
uh
bill
so I'll request the uh
432 432 colon 32-35 and just for your
information that it you won't find Right
to Farm it's called nuisance liability
of agricultural operations that's how to
say 432 colon 32 through 35.
33 34 and 35.
just for the record if I may you did say
it was nuisance liability
of agricultural operations thank you
it's relative to nuisances
foreign
there's barbs
all right then
um so for HB 252 the blue sheet we've
got one pro uh for the bill and then
online we've got five that support and
one in opposition
and with that I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 252.
foreign
guess what I'd like to do
is get a sense from the committee for
the bills that we've heard today
if
I know well next week we've got
three bills
let me get my paper here
we've got three bills that we're going
to hear next week
um
um well we can talk about that I guess
but I know what we had was HB 300
for next week's hearing
and we added also
HB 462
for
excuse me
for a 10 o'clock and at 10 o'clock we're
on the hearing uh for Tuesday
January 24th we had a 10 o'clock
starting at 10 o'clock at HB 300 and
then there's a companion bill to that of
funding
uh appropriation for that for uh HB 462
so we figured we could do those two
together
and then in the afternoon
we would have HB 326 which is the
rodenticide bill
um
I don't I I want to get a sense from the
committee if we should have an exec
session after that rodenticide bill so
that
um for some of the bills that we heard
today
can I have your
can't hear you
um I'm
I guess the my only concern is I have no
idea how long the rodenticide bill was
going to take I could imagine that
taking a half an hour or three hours
maybe not three hours did you get in
touch with representative cannon at all
yes she said and she said there were
there were several
um
several organizations that uh had
interest in that
um uh so
um I think the not remembering which one
specifically but perhaps Audubon and uh
the uh the folks who do
um Raptor
uh rescue and a couple of other
environmental organizations I think so I
but uh so I'm not sh but I haven't seen
any I haven't seen a whole lot of
um
emails coming in about that so I'm not
sure if it's you know sometimes that's
one way to gauge whether something is
going to be right busy
um
so uh what I'm and the reason I the I
guess my concern is I don't
I'm not I for scheduling exec sessions
I'd like it to be in such a way that we
can be kind of predictable about when
they're going to be happening as opposed
to this might happen somewhere between
two o'clock and right uh and I don't
think that uh any of the bills
that we're going to be exacting are
uh sufficiently
urgent that we it makes any difference
and I think and they're most of them are
not actually particularly tricky either
right
so um
so I think that uh it might make sense
to do the exact session for all of the
bills that we did today on the 30th uh
and unless there's something that needs
a
uh the only one I might say might take
longer would be the 369 if we want to
try to
um rewrite that I think that might need
to go to a study committee
and then I think that we might also
leave space on the 30th for executing
the bills we're hearing next week
can you mean the 31st the 31st yeah yeah
my calendar my head the calendar in my
head is kind of vague okay
um all right that seems reasonable
and uh so I think we can uh
we can look to
uh setting an exec session for the 31st
on the bills that we've heard yeah some
of the bills that we've heard
representative
oh second that Madam chair okay
good
anyone else yes yeah man one comment on
it seemed to me that HB 79
um
was a little bit behind executing but I
don't know if we want to look at that or
not okay so
um my my thought on that is that
um it probably makes sense to turn that
into a study committee and uh and I've
got a I talked with a commissioner about
that in terms of getting us some
language about what what would make most
sense to study in terms of the chapters
that uh that and and some and questions
that would sort of focus our work a
little bit and uh he said that he would
be able to get that uh get that that
suggested language to to us on not this
coming week but the next week so that
would make it I I'd be I'd be able to
write an amendment for that before the
31st
Madam chair yes I'm sorry go ahead no
that's okay thank you for taking my
question what what time were you
proposing for the exact session on the
31st
I think we would start that at 10. okay
in the morning okay
okay
um I'm just looking to see which ones
are the bills that we saw we heard today
were early bills
only one of them and that's the 128.
which was the seed bill yeah yeah okay
okay
um
probably fine
yeah so the 300 and 326 next week's
those are early bills also right and we
talked about
um I'm
don't remember what the number of it is
but it's my bill on uh the dedicated
making this
um
the soil stop going to it
all right so did we do we actually have
that in our folder yet
um
the bill for its
um it was one that was it was one of the
ones that was just sent out recently
um
foreign
that is
um changing where the
um Planet soil additive uh
fees go yeah that's 494 and that's an
early bill as well yeah so that's an
early bill I don't think it's going to
be hugely complicated we might want to
hear that after the rodenticides
um and if we
if we if we schedule the rodenticides
for an hour and that's probably enough
and then I don't think it'll take more
than a half an hour to do the
um
unless
do you imagine anyone's going to come
out of the woodworker posing that oh
what do it inside no the um the uh
changing moving the fund right uh for
fertilizers from the general funds to a
dedicated fund I have no idea okay
um
so do you wanna you wanna add that um HB
494 to next week's yeah
are at one and then we could do that one
perhaps at two and if it we need to push
it back a little if it would then it's
either blow up we can push it back like
half an hour or something well we well
you want to schedule that for two or two
thirty
um two okay 2 30 2 30. okay so I'll do
that let me you could put that one ahead
of it inside and put it inside actually
maybe we could yeah so make this at one
because yeah let's put the
put 494 at one and then rodenticides at
1 30.
that's why I'm here okay so I will make
I'll make that change with Heather yeah
and we'll have four bills next week
and then uh the subsequent week on the
31st we'll we'll do uh some an exact
session in the morning right
um from 10 to 12 you think that would be
sufficient yeah that should be that
should be sufficient okay and then we
can we'll talk further about scheduling
some other bills in the afternoon for
hearing that makes all right
um question
oh okay
all right
um
so with that okay do we want to get a
sense of where people are yeah why don't
we why don't we open that up okay I kind
of want to get a sense from everybody
um regarding the hearings today what
your thoughts are uh
so why don't I start with you
representative Bixby okay so um
um we should probably go through bill by
Bill but I don't I'm forgetting the all
right the title so when we start with HB
221 okay
okay relative to the acquisition of uh
agricultural land development rights uh
anybody have any thoughts on that
particular bill
representative NAB
um just having worked on many
conservation projects in our town and I
am very supportive of it land trusts are
often really useful at writing easements
and holding easements and monitoring
properties and the state is less so so I
think that flexibility is really
important and I fully support it
foreign
all right anybody have any major
disagreements with that bill
no
okay
um looks like that would be a an OTP
from this committee
and um
hb138 relative to the oversight of
commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food
anybody have any
comments about that that we heard today
no
okay
uh hb152 relative to soil and plant
additives
go ahead thank you madam chair
um over this summer or the fall we work
diligently on that particular chapter
and really did the Deep dive and I think
that representative Bixby did a great
job drafting the changes
thank you
okay I have no problem with that at all
I think I think you again you guys did a
very thorough uh Deep dive into that one
and it shows it's very very well put
together anybody else have comments
uh okay HB 79 relative to the authority
of the commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food to inspect
apples
so I know that representative Ankerberg
brought a
an amendment to that
pretty much to um
to to restrict it further down I make it
into a study committee we talked about
that and probably trying to turn this
into a study committee that looks to
coordinate uh 426 RSA 426 and 434.
what's your thoughts representative
Contour thank you madam chair
um I think that a study committee would
be the way to go because obviously where
there's one duplication there are others
and I think it's uh to take a look at
the statutes and find out where the
duplicates are and to make things more
streamlined would be the way to go
okay any other comments representative
Murray uh yes thank you madam chair I
also think that there may there may be
instances in where there need to be
other stakeholders who provide some
additional insights so the study
committee is pragmatic I think it makes
sense
anyone else have any comments
representative Potenza
I agree I think the study committee is a
great idea it seems as if everybody was
in agreement um that was even testifying
my question is does the
does the sponsor of the bill have to put
in an amendment for that does the does
this Committee just decide if it's going
to move to a study committee can you
tell me just a little bit about that
process well the committee is now in
possession of this bill so we can do
with it as we desire
um and I believe representative Bixby
was going to look at uh putting an
amendment together yes so um and just in
terms of process
um just to amplify what the chairperson
said uh
once a bill comes to a committee the
committee is basically determines what's
going to happen with it they may or may
not consult the the sponsor but the
sponsor is kind of out of the loop uh
and
um and for this particular Bill uh I
think that it's pretty clear that it we
going with a study committee makes sense
and we're going to get advice from the
Department from the commissioner about
uh how to look at those chapters of law
because that chapter or those chapters
because they're familiar with dealing
with the regulation of them and they
know what they do and don't uh you pay a
lot of attention to
quick follow-up yeah sure so
representative so on the 31st we let's
say that moves further it goes to study
committee then
um that would possibly then go when it
goes to session go on like a consent
calendar correct
um yes so uh if we vote unanimously in
terms of uh converting that to a study
committee with an amendment then it
would we would probably put on the
consent calendar and then it would go
over the Senate and then the Senate will
um we will make we will make our uh our
argument to the Senate to do it and they
probably will be fine with it
so okay representative Howard
thank you madam chairman
um I guess I have a question about uh
whether or not it would the study would
be limited to just that portion of the
set of rules or if we could expand it to
to address other redundancies in the
in in the set of rules that the
commissioner was talking about I think
it was phism
okay so
um just in terms of practicality
um studying one chapter is about as much
as as a study committee can handle and
one could sort of go with the ideal of
like looking at the entire rsas and
looking for problems but that's that's a
doomed Enterprise so you need to sort of
break it down into manageable chunks and
a chapter is about as much as a study
committee can manage and I'd like to
also add that we it makes more sense to
do a study committee than to send it to
a subcommittee
here because number one we'd have more
input from outside people
and number two they would be able to
take a lot more time
to go through and you probably need like
four meetings to get through what we're
proposing with this study committee so
study committee I think is the way to go
with this
any other comments on HB 79
representative Creighton uh yes ma'am
chair the uh so first of all it was a
great idea in my mind to take away that
regulation and reduce the redundancy and
I think capitalizing on that with a
committee I'm in general a committee
seems to be a way to just move things
along and and so I'm not I always I
won't always stand up and support a
committee in general but in a specific
case like this where you can reduce
regulation reduce redundancy and
capitalize on initiative that these guys
are taking I think it makes a lot of
sense
okay any other comments
okay when I also get a sense for where
we're all thinking about hb128 relative
to repealing State seed labeling license
requirements
anybody have thoughts on that
representative NAB
other Representatives put it well when
he said it felt like a law in search of
a problem
um I also felt like the commissioner
made a good point in saying that he
would have preferred the step come from
an actual seed seller to so it's not
clear to me that this is an issue that
needs to be addressed and needs to be
changed in this way
so I I don't feel supportive of it as it
is currently written anybody else
represent Howard
I um thank you madam chairman um I agree
with with um Allison uh sorry
representative knepp
um and also I think that they said in um
in the testimony that uh that it's not
one that they particularly enforce
anyway so it
um it seems like it sort of watered down
the well
represent Potenza
I agree I I believe if this was an issue
I think they should have had
um people that are that are doing this
that are selling seeds that um have some
expertise on it I don't feel that it had
enough substance for us to move that
forward
representative Murray
uh thank you madam chair um yeah I also
think that there are some other um
unintended consequences that this could
potentially have if it would move
forward the way it's written
okay
all right well
um
how about your feelings on HB 369 the
energy task force
representative burlog yeah I kind of
agreed with the commissioner Madam chair
that you're taking away time from their
UH responsibilities to look and create
this separate task force which
I'm sure they would say you know they
would need the funding uh you know to
get disorganized and to look into it
rather than just put the onus on the you
know the problem themselves to
investigate to see if there are funds
available to them and if there are they
should rightfully uh be entitled to
those within the inflation reduction act
I just don't think uh you know creating
this task force would be a good use of
resources
okay representative Creighton yeah the
the one comment and listen carefully to
the testimony but the the one comment
that resonated me with me is if they
passed this in August
and they gave that down to the uh the
different federal agencies that they
would not have had time to figure out
how they're going to implement these
different things so I think this is
maybe a little bit premature if you're
actually going for the money that came
out of that that bill
representative Bixby
um I like I I like the idea of figuring
out a way to support Farmers with this
uh with the car the capital costs of
moving solar forward on their Farms I um
I
uh I'm met I spent a little bit time
talking with uh the Hardys uh about
their operation down at Brookvale Farm I
know that they are
very
um
they're really attentive to what it
takes to make farming work in the
current situation which is a it's a very
challenging time to be a farmer in New
Hampshire and uh they are very good at
identifying opportunities to make their
farm work better and to serve their uh
customers better and to serve their
Community better I think that
it's worth trying to take a little bit
more look at it I think that the way
that it is currently written is
problematic and I think it might be
worth sending this to a subcommittee and
seeing if there is some way we can amend
it to actually get it to do the job that
it's intended to do I'm not sure I I
think that subcommittee will the
subcommittee will have to figure out you
know is there a way to fix this or is it
but I don't think we can figure out
whether it's fixable
um you know real you know this week so
yeah
I'm almost leaning to retaining the bill
um
and that way we can maybe talk about it
later on yeah I I think it I would be
more in favor of doing one one
subcommittee session and seeing if
there's something we can do and then if
that if we if we say if we decide it has
promise but we can't do it soon then
we'll then retain it and if it looks
like this is just
um not this is not the way at all the
way to do it and we can you know
find some other approach in the coming
year than we could itl it but I think
I'd like to investigate it before we
make that decision I agree uh
representative Compton thank you madam
chair
um
in listening to all of the testimony and
um probably somebody in the audience
isn't going to like what I have to say
um
but the New Hampshire Farm Bureau used
to have an energy subcommittee
that looks specifically at agriculture
issues in energy and the issues that
they're facing
um and in listening to
um
the folks from the Department of energy
and the Commissioner of Agriculture
um there is questions if there is even
funds available through a task force
such as this
um and I would like to see the Farm
Bureau Institute the energy committee
again uh to tackle on this instead of
putting it on the legislature and then
let them talk to us about what they
their findings are
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I also have heard from other
constituent stakeholders who have spoken
to not just traditional farming such as
Commodities like apples but other sorts
of agricultural products that energy is
a large portion of their
costs associated with doing the business
that they are doing and have looked to
other things like solar and are trying
to understand what is available to them
so I would be inclined as representative
Bixby said to at least give it
a good shot to kind of take a look in
subcommittee and see where we're going
with this on behalf of some of those
folks as well
okay representative Howard
thank you
um I agree with Representatives Bixby
and Murray I think it would be um
it's almost a call to action to have
something come out of this this
committee
addressing alternative energies on farms
it's sort of in my mind new to the
committee as I am it's a great
combination of Agriculture and
environment
representative Potenza
I actually uh I agree just wanted to
with representative rouliard am I
pronouncing it correct
um I think this is premature
um in regards with the task force if
there needs to be a subcommittee that
wants to speak on it great but it's if
these federal dollars are coming in and
they're going to be going directly to
Farmers I don't believe that we need to
create more bureaucracy or a task force
or a committee or anything like that
they're going to have access to those
funds there's many many agencies and
committees already in this state that
can help that I used to do a lot of
grants in higher education and I just
know that process so I really really
believe that
um if if it's necessary to have a have a
meeting on it or a subcommittee meeting
on it fine but I believe that this is
premature and
um and I know that energy is huge the
cost of running especially a small farm
is is
astronomical I have some friends that
have a farm in Loudon and they've
reduced their size now in half from
um in regards because of everything that
happened during the pandemic the height
of it and so it's um it's really hard
for them to make ends meet and energy is
a big deal so
my two cents thank you
for comments
okay we'll move to the last one HB 252
exempting agricultural operations from
certain Municipal noise ordinances
thoughts feelings
observations
representative Bixby yeah
yeah I think that
um
it I think it makes sense to go forward
with this with uh with an amendment that
would
um exclude the uh agritourism uh I think
that
um
the municipal
Association is always loaths to give up
any part of their purview but in this
particular case uh I think that
having a farmer's livelihood depend on
the sort of role of the daison who's in
their Town select board in any given uh
to to your term is not really a good way
to support New Hampshire agriculture I
agree with that thank you
representative NAB
um as a select board member I I have to
support the nhma but um I you know I the
size issue gives me a huge pause because
I think the definition of farms is so
broad that it concerns me a little bit
that anybody who has any sort of farming
operation on their property can say that
they're a farm and it seems like the way
the definition of farming is written
that is true so
um you know I I don't pretend to know
the answer to that problem but I think
it's a really I think it gives me
concern that the definition of farming
is so broad that this could be inclusive
of almost anybody that has any
production on their property
thank you representative Murray thank
you agree with
with always Leary when we're talking
about right to farm or we're talking
about I think that was 432 was that
correct
and the intersection of that with uh
this piece of legislation so I I want to
be very careful that we're not
butting up against that representative
come talk uh thank you madam chair I
just want to address representative
Murray
um the statute on nuisances and what we
call the right to farm was looked at
when all of these other things were
happening and this is how this came
about in discussions with the
commissioner and the policy director at
Farm Bureau and that's why this came out
so it doesn't isn't going to do anything
to harm that particular piece of
legislation
thank you
okay any other comments
I'm wondering if it might make sense to
send this to subcommittee to see if it
we could uh
do a little bit of narrowing on the you
know how we're defining Farm just in in
you know
um or or specif a little bit more
specification I think I'm not sure that
we'll come to the right answer in a
subcommittee but I but it might be worth
trying to uh you know do a little I'm
just wondering if you know
my
um my hat my quarter acre of production
would count as a farm under this uh on
under the current definition and I'm not
sure that I would be really the right
person to be qualified to take this
exemption a representative thank you
madam chair
um
I have a colleague of mine who had was
farming on a pretty large parcel of land
and was leasing it but due to it being
sold had to move to a small quarter acre
plot where they now are substantially it
is considered farming and they are
making a great living selling flowers
which is considered farming and to do
anything because of the size of their a
lot would be detrimental to them
representative Murray ah thank you madam
chair I also wonder about those types of
things that are vertical in nature not
necessarily horizontal like beekeeping
and other types of things where land is
not necessarily
um the primary factor in how beekeeping
Works
um so to the degree that
um well I understand that representative
bixby's point I do want to make sure
that we're also factoring in the to your
point the rather broad nature of types
of farming and I do understand your
point of
this the sense of of it being
potentially broad but I think it may be
an intentionally broad for a reason
okay representative Bixby yeah the one
thing that I I one thing I noticed in
the definition of farm doesn't seem to
have uh any indication of whether it is
being run as a business or as a hobby or
as a you know just growing food growing
food for yourself so I'm wondering where
the
if there's some sort of boundary where
we need that we need to set in that in
that regard
representative contour and then
representative knabb thank you madam
chair uh representative Bixby to your
point
um and I understand uh the definition of
farm is extremely broad but we have to
uh look and see you know if you're
growing food and or you're growing a
small garden on your property you might
be supplying food for your neighbors for
others or for the food pantry and
although it may not be a for-profit
business it is considered a farming
activity because you are helping others
in the community and I think we have to
be very cognizant of that when we're
dealing with food Security in this state
representative NAB
well sorry
um
I was going to ask before you just made
that point um is there any other way
that someone identifies themselves as a
farmer do they have any sort of permit
for selling I'm not sorry I don't know
the answer to it because I also have
this side note but I had an issue with
the constituent who wants to who was
talking about Peruvian he was a farm and
I said how do you prove you're a farmer
in the state he said well you can have
Farm plates but I just wonder if there's
a workaround to the size of the farm if
you you know besides like if you are
selling or you're
but representative suffocitis
representative Murray
thank you madam chair and the other
thing that I would like to make sure
that we're being mindful of is
homesteading and I think that we had
recently addressed the cap and lifted
that it was in 2020 or 2021 on the
dollar amount that um one one could earn
and so I do want to make sure that that
is also a type of farming Homestead
farming and
um I'm
curious just to sort of
see how those two intersect with
traditional quote farming representative
come talk uh thank you madam chair
canning and harvesting of vegetables is
considered a farming activity so
anything to anything to do with
basically your food is under that
activity so that would be consistent
with keeping the homestead
yep representative Potenza
I just wanted to
um just uh ditto with what you said and
I think that the longer that we
um go through all of this we are we're
one of the most
um
farming friendly states in the country
and I just I think this definition is
Broad by Design and it should be you
don't have to
um to be a farmer you don't have to sell
you don't have to have a business you
can just have a little stand there's I
have an uh very close by neighbor about
a mile away and they literally give all
of their extra vegetables from their
quote-unquote Farm they leave their you
know a little box that maybe give a
donation if you want to take their eggs
and stuff like that so I just think that
um we should uh we don't need to mess
with this at all so I'm for it and uh I
think we should move on okay well I know
that um representative come to us going
to have a few changes to make to this
Bill to that she's intending on bringing
an amendment anyway
I'm not so certain that we need to go to
subcommittee with this
um I don't know what's your thought
representative come talk
in a moment
um Madam chair I think that it we were
in agreement I was in agreement with the
commissioner uh commissioner Jasper and
with Rob Johnson that we need to exclude
the agritourism section of that you know
regarding uh you know people that have
weddings or bands or things like that on
their property and make that as an
exception to this other than that I
don't see any reason for this not to go
forward thank you representative Howard
um I I thank you I I
um respectfully disagree with with
representative I would um I don't think
we should
um just uh
um sorry
um agriculture
agricourism out of the out of the bill
maybe maybe make an exception for
non-farm loud noises like bands and
stuff like that but you know I could see
I I just think that the agriculture part
of agritourism needs to have the same
the same
um rules as agriculture outside of
agritourism with representative Morse
thank you my only concern with this and
and I like to get out and pound T posts
at six o'clock in the morning you know
before it gets hot in the summer and
everything too so I completely
understand my concern would be that in
more urban areas
it or in general if people were going to
start abusing this in any way with the
noise are we taking away the right of
you know municipalities to be able to
step in and address the situation
representative NAB
um I will say having met on this
Blackboard for four years I think the
only time we've ever had a problem with
the noise ordinance was a farm that runs
weddings out of their Barn so I strongly
agree with excluding agritourism I think
that's a big issue
um and makes us totally separate type of
noise than comes from farming activities
representative Bixby yeah just uh as an
explanation of the way that agritourism
is is built into the statute
um it is defined as a marketing activity
that is ancillary to the farming but you
have to have the the the the farm so the
farm you can't be an agitourism
operation without already being a fully
operational Farm
so uh so you can't so um I think that uh
that's
that um putting saying that agritourism
is excluded from this uh noise ordinance
or or whatever uh from from the excluded
from the exemption uh is appropriate
because it is specifically designed
defined as ancillary to the operation of
a fully operational Farm
okay
representative suffocitus oh
yeah
sure
I was going to say that
all right um I'm gonna wrap this up for
today I thank you all for your time and
your attentiveness and um well I guess
I'll see you next week
I do Republican caucus after here so uh
thank you very much we'll adjourn for
today
thank you